want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only tony
robbins
enjoy
people think they want to get rich by
doing this big hit
look at all the actors all the athletes
all the movie stars that you've seen
that made more money than god and now
they're bankrupt
because they made money and income
working
but they never figured out how to make
money work for them while they slept
they never made money they're slaves so
if you look at like 50 cent
he made a hundred million dollars on
vitamin water
someone gave him a tip and he went
bankrupt or right now i don't know if
it's really going to happen but the
newspapers are speculating now
you know johnny depp is going through
this divorce he made three quarters of a
billion dollars 750 million dollars
and you're saying you may go bankrupt
now because you're gonna have to give up
half in his cash position and he spends
30 000 a month on wine
and he took hunter thompson the reporter
and burned his body and paid three
million to blow his ashes into
the atmosphere so you can mess up now to
what you do or you can take a small
amount of money and just consistently
invest it
and you'll get where you want to be
financially one thing that
i met with uh david swenson he took one
billion turned into 24 billion
and two decades in 20 years mind
boggling a billion a year
right just think about that level of
doubling it's just mind-boggling
and i asked him i said what what are the
dials what are the only dials we can
touch and he said tony to increase your
return
there's only a few things you can do he
said you can make better selections of
stocks
he said you can have better timing he
said and you get a better asset
allocation he said the first two will
never
happen because the first two cost you
money got to hire somebody everybody's
wrong in the timing
he said after the location which simply
means dividing your money into different
buckets
some of those buckets are secure so that
even though you think you're going to be
a genius you're going to make money no
matter what
that money goes slower but it'll always
be there and it'll give you freedom for
the rest of your life
there's a growth bucket which is also a
risk bucket we forget that yeah
because one of these rate value taught
me so tony everybody invests
in what they think they know you grew up
with real estate you're not a genius but
you made money in real estate because
anybody can when real estate is going up
yeah yeah you think you're a genius
you think you know stocks oh you're a
genius you know in in 1999 right you
know you're a genius in 2000 you know
uh 10 when things started knowing that
he said whatever you invest in
in your lifetime that area is going to
drop 50 to 70 percent there's
zero exception show you mathematically
and it can show you historically
so he said you have to diversify even
though you don't want to
and you have to divide these monies up
so every one of them taught me different
asset allocations
but one the one that i think is the most
valuable for anybody to really take
advantage of is ray dalios because
rate value is figured out why is it in
2008
if your stock broker your financial
planner said we're going to protect you
we're going to put you half in stocks
and half in bonds
why did they both go down you weren't
protected at all seeming up in a 2000
and you figured something out when you
think you're in a balanced portfolio
you're not balanced
and the reason is stocks are three times
more volatile
than you'll find in bonds what does that
mean it means when you think you're 50
50
you're 50 50 with your money but you're
not 50 50 with your risk you're 95
at risk and 5 of the good side that's
why everybody loses so he figured a
formula because he said look someday i'm
going to be gone
yeah i want my kids to have the money
long term i want you know all the
philanthropic things i'm doing to be
taken care of
so he spent 15 years studying the
markets and figured out
how do i design a portfolio that'll make
money
every time like if it loses money it
lost in 75 years
it's lost 1.6 when it's lost but it's
been right 85 percent of the time
wow if you went to vegas and you were
planning to work for 75 years
and made money 85 of the time and when
you lost you lost 1.6
and when you gained you gained more than
10 the biggest loss in 75 years
is 3.95 less than four wow so why did
people not make it in the stock market
because when you take up 50
hit they all say stay in nobody the
average person never stays at sure if
you look at the last 20 years
the average person the stock market over
20 years from 1993 to 2013
has averaged 9.2 percent pretty cool
compounding double your money pretty
damn quick doing that right
but the average mutual fund investors
made 2.5
why because they freak out they sell
when it goes down they buy when it's
looking good it's the wrong time to buy
it
they don't know what to do so what ray
dalio strategy does and by the way
he's never shared this strategy ever and
he gives it in here he gives it here
which is mind boggling
i pushed him i teased him in the end i
said look you're not taking any more
money help the average guy out
he lays it out you can do it yourself or
you have someone else do it for you but
it takes 15 minutes a year
and 85 success over 75 years and i could
take any time here last 30 years
you lost money four times one of those
was point zero zero three percent so
it's really breaking things
and again the most ever lost less than
four percent average one point nine
percent so if you're looking for a plan
i put some money there and the other
money that i would do is i take some of
that money and i look at what are the
biggest trends
i have a lot of my money also in senior
housing and the reason is twofold um
it's a demographic inevitability there's
this giant wave of baby boomers
and there isn't enough senior housing to
take care of them and i also i like it i
like to create a quality place for
someone to be able to be live and take
care of and so forth
but there's huge income from it and
there's the growth in the asset itself
what's your definition of greatness um
i don't know i think everyone has
greatness i don't like that separation i
i respect it because in sports i think
it's really easy to measure but sports
is one aspect of life
you know i think everyone has the
opportunity great to me being the
greatest being outstanding
to stand out from all the rest and and
as you know in sports it can be by you
know a few
microseconds right you know an olympics
you know it could be a nose hair
and you stand out if you stand out you
show the people what's possible
not everybody likes that some people get
angry and think you're showing them up
other people get inspired i've always
been inspired by somebody who's the best
in the world at what they do
and so i think greatness is somebody who
just will not settle
and finds a way to do be share and
create in life what they want
as opposed to fitting in i think most
people are trying to
not be rejected i you know i wrote in
this book you know i took a
quote from aristotle saying you know how
do you really
live your life well if you don't upset
anybody it's really simple don't do
anything don't say anything don't be
anything and everybody will like you you
know
but if you want to have a quality life i
think you just have to put yourself on
the line and
so to me greatness is people that put
themselves on the line they keep growing
they won't settle
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i have
designed a free training program just
for you
where every day for the next 254 days
i'll send you
an email with an unlisted video to help
you boost your confidence
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
and so i want you to build the habit of
self-belief and self-confidence
it's 100 free the link to join is in the
description below
so if you want to change your life my
friends you got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus
40 of all jobs they project in the next
10 years are going to disappear because
of technology
business is about constantly not only
adding such massive value doing more for
others than anybody else but it's also
simultaneously
about your own psychology it's your
ability to go through thresholds of
control
we live in a culture where most people
are dabblers today because
today if you ask me what does it take to
be happy and give it to you one word
progress progress equals happiness when
you're making progress in your body even
if you're not there yet you feel good
you achieve your goal and you just sit
around you're not happy we got to grow
we got to make progress
it's easy to make progress in the
beginning of something in the beginning
of a relationship who doesn't have a
good time
right in the beginning of starting a
business if you love what you're doing
of course you're gonna have a great time
in the beginning ending it's easy a job
it's fun in the beginning it's novelty
it's new
mastery is when you've worked you know
in the beginning of learning a sport how
fast you learn tennis i mean just like
zooms up here you didn't know anything
you thought love you know was an emotion
you find out it's a score you know
you go like this but then you hit this
plateau and most people end up plateau
they go
wrong job right wrong relationship wrong
business
because it's not instantly fulfilling
them but the people that go i'm going to
fight through and go deep i'm going to
find a way to break through i'm going to
find a way to learn and know more about
this any human life so that i can help
as many human beings as possible and it
won't be because i've lived it
there is a power in mastery and how many
people do you know are really committed
to mastery today most people dabble in a
million things they master nothing and
they wonder why they're unfulfilled
because they're running for the sugar
the next thing that feels good instead
of getting past what doesn't feel good
and getting to where you own
something i went through a divorce i
decided i i met a woman
fell in love with her and fell in love
with her kids she'd been married twice
before me she was 12 years my senior
so i was 24 and had a 17 year old son
instantly an 11 year old a five-year-old
and
one on the way really great lady but
we're completely different no one tells
you how to
pick your partner but i fell in love
with the children so i was like
i i don't want to lose these kids you
know so i eventually decided to get a
divorce when i got the divorce
it was a not happy divorce from the
standpoint if i tried to give her half
of everything but they got it ten times
most
yeah eight times and a ten times
multiple on all my companies in those
days i didn't have 31 i had like seven
and they were small companies they
weren't billion dollar companies they
were like
less than 100 million most of them yeah
and some of them were only dependent
upon me like
like a doctor if i don't show up the
whole thing falls apart
and so i'm looking at this i got to pay
her 8 and 10 times i got a pair of 50
million dollars and i didn't have 50
million dollars
so i settled on 42 million i had to pay
for 42 million when i didn't have it and
i started over
at 39 years old and i had to pay her not
only
42 million but i pay a million dollars a
year
for 17 years i was only married to her
for 14 years right
wow so i just paid that off a couple
years ago
and the reason i tell you the story is
in the beginning
i had to pay her a million dollars a
year plus i had to pay the taxes on it
before i
ate it was and when i met her she was
broke
now i was broke and that was the best
the world was doing but the power of
that was
when i wouldn't let go when i finally
said i'm gonna stop being angry
i'm just going to automate it let go my
capacity grew
10-fold it's like i never looked back it
was like because i
had to come up with an additional
million dollars i had to think bigger i
had to do things better so i started
creating
new relationships new partnerships new
businesses and it made me grow to a
5 billion a year company set of
companies versus
not even a little more than 100 million
back in those days so
in eight years my life has transformed
because i
i put that tax on myself and i invested
heavily
and i didn't have the money to do it but
i did it anyway because i had to and the
second thing i tell people is
feeding your mind is great but you've
got to also strengthen your body and you
do that as an athlete naturally
i learned to do that because fear is
physical right you know you feel it and
if you go work out if you go lift if you
go run even if you're out of shape you
just go from an intense walk
that experience alone changes your life
every day in my life the first thing i
do before i do my priming
if i'm one of my homes i jump in some
hot water for fun and i jump in freezing
water and i have you know a river you
know
and one of my homes in sun valley and
i've got cold plungers everywhere so i
go in 57 degrees of water
boom and what it does is like it's
teaching my brain i
do i tell my brain what to do and it
doesn't it doesn't feel like it doesn't
want to do it
and every cell in your body is alive
right so it doesn't have to be like two
hours worth of something it could be
something you do for 30 seconds but it's
training your
body to be strong because a strong body
could strong mind and vice versa
we all have a need for certainty we have
a need to know we can avoid pain
that we can be comfortable some people
do that when they're stressed by smoking
some people work out hard to deal with
some people eat
to try to get that comfort back but if
you are certain every moment of your
life you know what people are going to
do when they're going to do it how
they're going to do it you'll be bored
out of your mind so we also need
uncertainty
if you have too much uncertainty you
freak out if you have too little you
feel bored out of your mind and you get
uncertainty or variety by a great
conversation
by making love by taking on a new job or
a new career a new opportunity you get a
million ways the question is do you meet
your needs in ways that are positive or
negative
because sugar will make you feel good in
the moment but feel good long term
smoking a cigarette will make you
comfortable
and certain but it might be variety it
changes how you feel when you're
stressed so it meets two needs
that's why it's not sustainable that's
what makes somebody addicted
find a role model you know it seems
impossible until you see somebody who's
done it so
yeah you know ray dalio is one of the
greatest investors in history the guy
was
a caddy right you know his dad was a
jazz musician his mom was a homemaker
you know he's worth 14 billion dollars
he found someone to mentor him he found
well he found multiple people to model
right right you don't always find a
mentor but you find somebody you can
model
and when you start seeing that somebody
else can do it and you see they really
did
you start to believe you start to get
certainty where your focus goes energy
flows yes
because it just takes you to that right
place then the intent part sneaks in
there
is the intent because you've got to pick
what you want to do or just do something
and you'll figure it out as you go
you need to be clear what it is you
really want i always tell people you
know
know not only what you want but why you
want it i know this is simplistic but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier a great lady and
you could just see she wants to have a
new business but she never sat down to
even put a plan together and says why
aren't i taking action well
when you're not sure what you're going
to do you're going to hesitate and
hesitation kills momentum and momentum
is what makes
a sports team win it's what makes an
athlete a business person win
when you get momentum it's like takes
enormous energy to get a rocket out of
our
you know our gravitational pull of the
earth but out of the solar system is
easy once it has momentum it takes less
fuel less energy
starting a relationship starting a
business changing your body it takes so
much in the beginning
but once you get going it's actually
really easy you need to be clear what it
is you really want i always tell people
you know
know not only what you want but why you
wanted i know this is simplistic but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier
a great lady and you could just see she
wants to have a new business but she
never sat down to even put a plan
together and says why aren't i taking
action well
when you're not sure what you're going
to do you're going to hesitate and
hesitation
kills momentum and momentum is what
makes a sports team win it's what makes
an athlete a business person win
when you get momentous like takes
enormous energy to get a rocket out of
our
you know our gravitational pull of the
earth but out of the solar system is
easy once it has momentum it takes less
fuel less energy
starting a relationship starting a
business changing your body it takes so
much in the beginning
but once you get going it's actually
really easy now i don't tell people to
believe spiritually but i believe that
ultimately whatever you believe you've
got to live it and it should lead to
growing and giving if you're growing you
feel alive
if you're giving you feel ten times more
life and i think
if someone can celebrate and give then
that spiritual state so to me
those are the areas i look at mastering
you know business
for sure but it's the areas of life that
matter most and
most of where we spend our time doesn't
make people feel fulfilled that's why
the average person
is not fit and healthy the average
person is not in a relationship where
they have tremendous passion
you know i'm not a dummy i'm not a
positive thinker i know the truth the
average person is not successful in
business the average person is not
earning what they want to earn
but you know what very few people have
those things but a few do
a few are happy fulfilled spiritually
alive
financially strong their business is
growing they have passionate love
affairs
and i'm obsessed with finding the few
who do and find out what they do
different teaching to everybody
you know i interviewed all these nobel
prize guys as well as all these
self-made billionaires
and one of them uh was a man named
[ __ ] was really brilliant
he said you know what people don't
invest because a they say i can't
own the money but you know we're all
good at dieting tomorrow you know
i'm gonna go to diet tomorrow we all
believe it or we're all good at saving
tomorrow we're not gonna save today
because we want to spend the money but
we'll save in the future
so he said i took that pattern and
figured out a strategy
and he proved it worked in the midwest
the united states with blue blue-collar
workers who'd never saved a dime
he went and said i know you say you have
no money
i'd ideally like you to save at least
five percent but minimum
promise me three and a half percent
because no one's gonna miss three and a
half percent
you'll adjust that easily but here's
what we're going to do we're going to do
this plan called save more for tomorrow
we're going to go to your employer
and you're going to tell them whenever
you're going to raise whatever it is
next year two years ten years doesn't
matter when
five percent whatever the first five
percent of money goes straight into this
account
well within 15 years these blue collar
workers were saving an average of 15
percent
and the top 40 were saving 20. when you
save 20
you know i mean that's that's the
example of the guy from you know who
goes and he's got 70 million dollars he
saved 20
over time so anyone can do it everybody
makes you more of what you are if you if
you're mean you got more to be mean with
if you're
you know giving as you are and your team
is you're gonna have more to give with
so i think it just magnifies it doesn't
change anybody but it magnifies it and i
think most of us have so much emotion
tied up around money because we
associate emotions that are more
important to us like freedom
to that or security and when you get to
it also people don't like to compare
around that area so
what i try to do when i in this latest
work i did with my book money master the
game was to show people
how to master money instead of being
mastered by it because you either
mastered masters you
and and trying to pretend it doesn't
matter in the world we live doesn't make
sense
the real secret is find a way to add
more value to other people than any
other human being
in your industry in your category and if
you do that you won't have to worry
about money whatsoever
understanding the life cycles of
humanity there's a book called
generations
it's a big book it's i think a thousand
pages 800 pages
but it's a book worth meaning because it
shows you how as
every 100 years 1800 years we went
through the same cycles like what we've
just gone through economically in 2008
happened 80 years before and you can go
through a thousand years of roman
history and you see it and when you
begin to
be able to anticipate what's coming you
know how to take advantage of the season
some people freeze the death in the
winter people that are prepared might
snowboard or ski and have a good time
so it's a brilliant book and it's by
strauss and how
is there something small you've done you
know an example was
giving money to you know that child was
a great example of that but there's
something recently you've done that's so
small that you're like
really proud of i you know a lot of
people don't
think proud is a good term i think it
actually is
um ego is edging god out that's when you
make [ __ ] up to make yourself feel good
but i think if you've really done
something you know you have and no one
could take that from me
and so i'm proud of who i am as a man
i'm proud of
the things that you know what goes on
when the camera's not on
and there are people around me all the
time that will tell the people stories
about what i'm really like so i don't
have to communicate that to people it
gets shared
so um i don't know i don't know there's
there's so many things in life i don't
measure them as big versus small
sure my my wife was somebody who would
see one person and be thrilled
and i had to see you know ten thousand i
think so she's balanced it out for me i
still
i feel like life is short and while
you're here i wanna have the most impact
that i can so i go deep
and i go wide um but every interaction
to me is an important interaction
and and sometimes that interaction is
just being kind i know it sounds stupid
but
kindness can to the right place the
right time you know somebody can be
suicidal you don't know you're being
kind and changing their state
yeah there's a it's an interesting story
of um there's a gentleman who
who wanted to kill uh nixon and
he couldn't get access to nixon it's
true story and so he became
he wrote a journal that's how we know
the details of it and he decided he's
gonna go after wallace
and go shoot wallace and he actually did
do that shooting
and when they read his journal it was
fascinating he didn't want to kill nixon
because he didn't like him or wallace
he just want to be famous he wanted to
be worth something
and one of the reasons he didn't tell
nixon is he was going after nixon
and he was this far from the president
and old woman
bumped into him just as he's reaching
his pocket to get this gun
and in the middle of this everything's
frenzy he wants to shoot to become the
most famous man you know another one of
those assassins
and this woman grabbed his hand and said
i'm so sorry i'm just so sorry
and he said in his journal afterwards
his hand was on the gun wow
and her looking at his eyes with this
love in her eyes and this kindness in
her eyes
he said i couldn't make her witness that
and he put the gun away oh man that
saved nixon's life
wow right soon after wallace you know
but that's the power of a moment of
kindness so i think we underestimate
uh you know somebody came and fed my
family was 11 years old you know um
obviously the person must not be alive
still because i've told the story and i
haven't reached out to you man reached
out to me yeah
but i mean imagine what the impact of
that was by that one little act of
kindness
what should i be you know going all in
on should
as you know millennials that are
starting businesses like many people in
our community uh they're
you know going all in on their business
and you know they're sacrificing profit
for growth you know
so yeah they don't have that much spare
change what what's your advice there
what are your thoughts
i'm really glad you asked me that
question because every entrepreneur i
meet i have this conversation with
one-on-one people that are my friends
um and i do it in my business seminars
too when i show people i do business
boot camps and i
i spend five days showing how to grow
their business 100 plus and then i take
a half a day and show them what to do to
have a second business here's what i'd
say to you if you're a founder out there
if you're
somebody's starting an organization the
amount of money that you
get whatever cash you have if it's a
growing business
will always be eaten up by the
organization so a friend of mine ken
blanchard who wrote the one minute
manager books you may have read
years ago i met him 30 years ago and i
helped him take five strokes off his
golf game so he thought i was god
and i don't play golf i just know what
to do here and here with somebody
and so afterwards he goes i want to do
something for you i said look i
don't do anything about two months later
calls me up says i want to have lunch
with you i want to give you a gift
he said i want to share with you the
best financial advice that changed my
life
so what is it he said this very wealthy
friend of mine saw i was writing a book
and he saw us growing my business and he
said i want to tell you something
a business he said what i told you
earlier we'll take whatever cash is
there because a growing business
there's always needs he said you have to
draw a line in the sand and he said your
book should be the first line in the
sand you should put none of that money
in your company
the clients that like the book will
become clients of the company
and you shouldn't take that money you
should put an investment account that
you don't touch
and it continues to compound to create
financial freedom
he said tony i took his advice and then
i went through three different stages
where he almost went bankrupt in the
business
because i had so much cash and money i
wasn't stressed
so i was they'll keep my head straight
and run my business better because if
you think about and i bet i did that too
i did
my first books now i give away all the
profits in my books my first books and
my first infomercials yes
and i work you know 275 days a year on
the road
i never earned as much as i did by
compounding because compounding
changes the game so what you have to do
if you're a business owner
you have to get yourself where you say
i'm going to put a tax on my business
not the government tax my tax my future
self is going to be free forever
because look in business 96
of businesses don't make it in ten years
i'm sure all of yours will
but even the four percent that make it
aren't necessarily profitable
so and the reason is because government
can change the rules
right taxes can shift radically affected
clients shift their preferences
technology new competition so i tell
everybody i believe you'll make your
business succeed but
everybody should have a business on the
side with no employees no moving parts
20 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes a year
to rebalance it
so that if anything happens here you're
still strong and you can make this
stronger
or if this goes well and this goes well
as well you have twice as much money and
you're there
but you got to understand what this
compounding does right this compounding
you don't need a lot of money to get
really really wealthy
you know the example of one examples i
put in the book here was
the example of a man who talks to his
son he's 18 years old
and the man understands finance and
understands the power of compounding so
he says to a son
you got your first job you're 18. i'm
going to require
that you take 300 every month 150 bucks
a paycheck and we're going to automate
it to the separate account and it sounds
like i can't do that he goes
let me tell you why you want to do it
it'll be up to you if you promise to do
that you really do it you automate it so
you don't see it
and you do that for eight years you'll
never have to invest again and you'll be
financially set for life this thing goes
come on dad
eight years three dollars a month what
is that if he does the math he goes
that's twenty eight thousand
you know over here twenty eight thousand
eight hundred dollars twenty eight
thousand eight hundred how's that going
to do anything especially if i don't
have any more money after 27 years old
he goes let me show you son the market's
gone up ten percent
over 30 years let's apply a lower number
let's do eight percent be conservative
let me show you what the numbers are
when they compound you know how much he
has when he retires
1.8 million dollars and all he put in
was 28
800. so how do we um
invest without fear of oh it's going
down i need to take it out or like
trying to time it how do we do that
great question it's one of the main
reasons i wrote the book i always tell
people if you just read the second
chapter of the book and nothing else
it'll change your life you're doing that
with multiple chapters but
that chapter is really about teaching
people
that winter is coming we all know
winter's coming right quite a phrase
but that winter is the best time on
earth and i know that's counterintuitive
and i don't mean like being a positive
thinker i mean
pure facts so in the book i take you
through 10 facts i'll give you a couple
of them right now
the first fact i give people is why do
people not invest
they're afraid of failing they if you're
a millennial
right so you grew up witnessing 2008
when you're still relatively young how
old are you now
33. okay so you were what 27 what were
you
what
what 2008 um yeah 27 yeah 27 28 years
old
so you're a young man and you're
watching the world melting down in front
of you
for most millennials they are the first
generation
since the generation that went through
the depression that is not investing
at the ratio they need to even close
have more than everyone probably right
with all those they have
more college debt than everyone
absolutely true i have a friend that has
four hundred thousand dollars in debt
dental school president obama just paid
off his debt five years ago while he was
still president
no i swear to god oh my god it's
mind-boggling and he had a bunch of
uh scholarships for the last bit it took
him that long so what i tell them is
listen
debt paying off your debt's not enough
you've got to become an owner or you're
always going to be in that place so yes
pay off your debt but here's what you
need to know
you gotta become an owner you gotta get
in the game but you gotta understand the
rules of the game you don't know the
rules of the game the old phrase is you
get you know what a person with
experience meets a person with money we
know the phrase
the person the money ends up with leaks
ends up with your money right yeah so i
teach people the rules of the game so
they don't get screwed but
the most important thing is this
winter's coming
but people react so let's take last year
last january
2016 we had the worst stock market
opening in the history of the stock
market
first first i think was 10 days yeah
there was a drop of 2.3
trillion dollars with the t crazy
everybody's freaking thinking
the bear market's here the market's over
the crash is here
i think the market dropped 800 points
one day and on that day
all the richest people in the world were
in davos switzerland you know for the
big conference that they do every year
and they went there msnbc went there and
everybody's freaking let's have what are
we going to do and they said let's go
ask ray dalio now
your listeners may or may not know ray
value as
if if you're not in the financial
business probably never heard of them
they've probably heard of warren buffett
but ray talia's done more
you have a 5 billion net worth and 100
million dollars to give him or he
wouldn't talk to you 10 years ago now he
doesn't care for [ __ ] how much money you
have he won't talk
because he's got a closed font but they
go and they put value on television
cnbc he's the king what do we do and he
says well
you don't need to panic corrections
happen all the time yeah but you need a
strategy that when markets go up and
down you don't go up and down
and he said i spent 15 years of my life
to perfect such a strategy all of my
money's in that plan
and he said it's called all seasons and
i've never revealed it before but i
gave it to tony robbins he extracted
from me and it's his book so you got to
go read his book three says on national
television the data markets are crashing
and that day they give you an idea which
is the beginning of february i think it
was nine days in february the market was
down
nine percent in the first five weeks of
the year
his strategy which he gave me which is
made money
85 of the time for the last 75 years
wow it's averaged a 10 percent return
just under
and the average loss of when it fifteen
percent loss was 1.6 right so if you go
to vegas and you could spend
85 percent of time make money and when
you made money it was 10
you lost is 1.6 you go forever his plan
made two percent while the market was
down 9. so it was up 11
difference now i'm not suggesting that's
the only strategy to do there's many his
is the smoothest ride
with the least risk but what it did was
combination of that and then right after
that i interviewed uh fed chair alan
greenspan
he was the head of our economy the most
powerful man in finance for 19 years
four
presidents he was there ready i was just
for president clinton this last week he
was
he was the fed chair for him and i
interviewed him for like two hours you
know
three hours off stage two hours in front
and i asked him in the very beginning of
this thing i said to him i said look
if you could be put the fed today what
would you do and he looks at me and as i
said he leans forward and he says
resign so i look at that and go oh my
god i need to write a book that will
free people so
here's what will for you everyone's
afraid of the crash so
here's we need to know two terms you
should understand correction versus
crash
anytime the market drops from its high
by 10
or more up to 20 it's called a
correction right if it drops
20 or more up to 80 like in
you know the the great depression then
it's called a crash or called a bear
market
okay so how often does a correction
happen how
how often we have to prepare for it
since 1900
we've had a correction on average every
year wow for 116 years
so when is winter coming this year on
average it's like how often does winter
come you wouldn't be surprised if it's
stormed in rain
now some winters are long some are short
some are harsh some are light
but winter always comes so i wasn't
panicked when this happened
last year i'm not panicked whenever it
happens because i know it's supposed to
be
yeah how long does it last average 56
days
okay so just under two months what's the
average drop during that time
14 over the last 30 years 13.5 of the
last 100 years so i use the more recent
one
14 get your attention right 14 you get a
little gut check
but here's you need to know 80 of all
corrections never become a bear market
80 so all this fear and what people do
is what you said you did is
they see it it's freaking out and losing
money i'm the hell out of here and they
get out
the stock market never took a dime from
anybody only you can take it from it
you sold that's why you lost right right
so if you look back and say what was it
like in 2008
i remember vividly being with my
platinum partners and saying you see
these 80
stocks this is six months before the
crash i told them in april i brought
them
to dubai and i said these stocks are
going to go to eight
and some are going to go to a buck and
by october and i told them what to do so
they were able to get out october i go
on the today show in october of 2008 and
they go
tony there's been three trillion dollars
meltdown
pump the country up you got four minutes
like ready go that's not what i do
first of all and i said i'd be a lie i'm
not going to po at that point the 80
stocks rate i said some of those i said
i'm not a market forecaster but i work
with paul tudor jones one of the
greatest investors in the history of the
world
in the biggest market crash in history
you know 1987
he made 200 wow when everybody else was
losing their entire life
i've been coaching him continuously now
for 24 years every single day
so i said i've worked with the best in
the world and they're telling me based
on history in the 30s in history in the
70s
this eight dollar stock somewhere gonna
be a buck and i remember the day
in march of 2009 citibank which had been
i think 70
sold for 97 cents you could go
and take your money out of the atm yeah
it cost you more to take your money off
and to own the bank
right and then i told people it'll jump
from 99 cents to
six ten twelve dollars in a month or two
is exactly what it did right
so what you got to know is corrections
happen every year you've got another
couple months gotta know it's 14 and you
won't lose
because eighty percent time it doesn't
go to a bear now what about the bear
the bear market it happens to give you
an idea in the last hundred years every
three to five years
you've gone eight without one we're way
overdue yeah
so in modern years last 30 years it's
about every five years
the average length of a bear is one year
the average drop is 33
a third of those drops go 40 or above
that i don't care how well prepared you
are that's a scary thing yeah
but it is the greatest opportunity in
your lifetime to go from wherever you
are financially to where you want to be
i hope your audience is listening right
now
hear me if you want a leapfrog and
you're a millennial and you think
there's no future or
you're you know a baby boomer and you
think you're too old and it's too late
the greatest gift you have is coming you
know it doesn't sound like it this is
not positive thinking [ __ ] this is
the truth
wall street the stock market is the only
place that when things go on sale people
freak out
if i said you like ferraris sure if i
said to you ferraris go on sale for 50
percent off
awesome but when i tell you apple's on
sale for 50
off you go oh what am i gonna do here
what's wrong the whole world's coming to
an end
if you think about it how old are you 33
33 so let's assume
if you were 35 and you lived to 85 you
got 50 52 years ahead of you
that means you have 52 more corrections
to live through right
that means you're probably in those 50
years gonna have
ten more bear markets to live through if
you're gonna have a gut checks every
time or you're gonna leave out of it
right if you didn't participate because
you thought oh the market's too volatile
i can't trust it all that stuff you
missed 250 percent return in the last
eight years
i mean you've missed out on everything
while you're waiting for things to be
better and if you won't do it when it's
like this
when it crashes you're not going to get
in so
here's the good news about the bear good
news about the bear average ones a year
could be longer but that's the average
could be shorter but here's what's cool
every single bear market in the history
of the united states has led to a bull
market
meaning right afterwards so 2008 this
plummeting
what happened in 2009 up 67
in a year i can show you every single
bear market and the next year when it
comes out it's this explosion
now that's not true in every market in
the world it's true for two centuries in
the united states
that's why warren buffett says i want to
be greedy when people are afraid
and i want to be afraid when people are
greedy if you remember 2008 he was
telling everybody bye he was having the
time of his life
bye bye bye everything's on sale so what
you have to do to become unshakeable
is turn when i only the metaphor i use
is the turn the snake into the rope
meaning
we all know the story it's the middle of
the night you're walking through the
yard or someplace and you see a snake
and you're freaked out you pull back you
come in the morning and it's a rope
once you know it's a rope you're never
afraid again yeah i want to take for
people investing
and show them how to turn that snake
into the rope it really is
what made me effective was that i
wouldn't get involved in a business just
to make money i'm involved with the
business because it's a mission it's
something that i think can change
somebody's life
and whether it's something as simple as
stem cell business or whether it's
lafc a soccer team i own or whether it's
a resort in fiji
i try to do something that's going to
change their lives and the whole focus
in business is add more value
there is no other rule if you do more
for others than anybody else does in the
marketplace
you'll build a brand people get on their
knees and reach behind
a soda pop to get a coca-cola even
though coke doesn't win most the taste
test it is the brand
you will become the brand if you can do
more for others than anybody else does
and i hope that your
audience the reason they're listening to
you is to figure out how to add more and
more value to the marketplace
what is it that prevents people from
doing the things they already want to do
in life
the most basic answer i'm sorry it's so
simple but it's true it's fear
you know but people making this complex
process this woman has told me that i
don't understand why they don't do this
why i feel this way
it's called fear everybody's afraid
we're not enough everybody's afraid
we're not rich enough smart enough young
enough
quick enough fast enough it's human
nature but the secret is to do it anyway
i know that sounds so simplistic
my work when i'm working with somebody
is showing how to condition themselves
like building a muscle
so that you take action first
automatically because if you don't do
that it's hard you lose momentum it's
like how do i get started where do i go
and i tell people throw a rock wherever
it drops start there the next person
walks by i go you're the first person
after the rock
do anything to start the process of
moving forward
rather than fear stop you then i
developed this little system and the
system was really simple and i tell
people now as i say number one
every single day you got to feed and
strengthen your mind
until you do that you're always going to
be in fear because fear is automatic
the human brain is designed for survival
it's not designed for success your brain
is not designed to make you happy that's
your job
right the only way we're going to do it
is if you feed your mind because
otherwise
weeds grow automatically by drinking my
coach your mentor jim rohney's telling
me so tony
every day you got to stand guard at the
door of your mind you got to watch
what's going on because if you're not
careful
stuff will go in he's saying all the
times it's somebody who cares about you
said you know
if you're your family yeah if your worst
enemy puts
sugar in your coffee he said what
happens i said you got sweet coffee
because what if your best friend by
accident or your family don't mean to
they drop one drop of stricken on your
coffee you're dead he said so life sugar
and strychnine and watch your coffee
right right so every day i decided i i'm
old enough
honestly there was no internet those
days i'm pretty ancient i used to go to
the library because the only place to go
and i would read biographies i'd read
people's lives and make me go wait a
second as bad as i think it is
the greatest people in the world had it
worse sure so there's something here so
you feed your mind i i'm jim rohn you
say to me
skip a meal but don't skip reading i
said read 30 minutes a day i don't give
a damn what it is
today i don't mean internet crap i mean
read something
a biography read something that's a
strategy read something's going to
change your life
the goal if you own a business and i
would assume a lot of your viewers are
business owners are getting started in
business
no matter how good you are in business
think about this the one universal rule
that
it's in finance know is diversification
it's the only free lunch you've got to
diversify
because if you put all your eggs in one
basket no matter how good the basket is
one day that real estate market that
stock market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in
radel you showed me statistically it'll
drop 50 to 70 percent on a day
now if you're later in life when that
happens it's over for you right
so you have to diversify and yet most
people they know real estate so they do
it or they know stocks they do it or
they grew up with their hand
their parents flipping things and it's
the wrong thing to do
so you've got to diversify in order for
you to be able to truly succeed
and that's why when you own a business
yeah
if you put all your money in your
business which is what most of us do
naturally
you see a lot of risk yeah you put all
your eggs in one basket
and there's things that can happen i
mean you know you're let's say you spent
20 years
and you figured out how to put together
the ultimate map
you know and you remember garmin came
out with this thing called the tomtom i
don't remember
it was a breakthrough they were making
like 100 million or something or yeah
yeah six months later what happened the
iphone came out with google maps these
little bastards this
is my friend came out with it put google
maps put their own map on here and
asked how much zero what's it gonna do
to your business when someone takes your
product reserve and gives away for free
so i always tell people competition
happens
technology happens what you must do is
have a second business
with no with no moving parts no people
no time maybe it takes you
two to three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two three times a year that's it yeah go
on with your life
now if there's a trouble in your
business you're financially set i in my
life
at 31 companies now we have you know
what we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we do five
billion in sales
i mean i that used to be you know me and
my seminar business it's grown
geometrically
but with all those moving parts the only
way i've been able to succeed is because
i've taken every one of those businesses
and i've diversified my assets so that
when things were in trouble
i still have enough economics to take
care of myself and keep the business
going so
everybody needs to create a money
machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about if you
look at what makes people happy it's
really two things it's
progress like even you know you achieve
your goals and oftentimes people achieve
a goal and then they go this all there
is
it's because it didn't meet their deeper
needs our need is to keep growing
you know business is growing or it's
dying a relationship's growing or it's
dying so
if you're feeling like you're not even
there but you're making progress it
feels alive because we all grow or die
and then when you make progress
when you grow you got something to give
my very first teacher was a man named
jim rohn
and he was a personal development
speaker and he had this
three and a half hour seminar he would
do that i went to when i was 17 years
old i was already reading books i was
obsessed with wanting answers i want to
know what made the difference in the
quality of people's lives
not because i was intellectually
interested but because i grew up in a
really tough environment
i had four different fathers there was a
lot of my mom was a great human being
who loved me dearly but
she you know abused both alcohol and
prescription drugs so she was
very physically abusive and i was
believe it or not 5-1 in high school as
a little guy so
i got the you know what beat out of me
pretty regularly for things that i
didn't do anything to do with
and so it made me try to figure out what
made her work what makes life work made
me more of a practical psychologist
and the modeling concept came because
jim rohn used to have this phrase he
said success leaves clues
he said if if there's anything you want
in your life don't
assume that somebody has some special
gift they may have a gift but they
probably developed it
most of it and if you sow the same seeds
you'll reap the same reward so figure
out what this person's doing different
than anyone else
and do that he used to have a funny way
of describing he used to say
tony find out what poor people read and
don't read it
it's like because he said that's the
fabric they're trying to build their
mind from find out somebody who's
successful
wealthy not just financially wealthy but
somebody who's rich emotionally and
spiritually and physically and
financially
and find out how do they live their life
differently what are the things they
believe what are they what are some of
the daily disciplines that they're a
part of
and so really early on i got obsessive
about wanting to have all the answers so
i said i'm gonna read a book a day
because i figured you know a person
takes 10 15 years of their life
they pour two or three four years into
this book
and you absorb in a few hours literally
a decade's worth of life experience and
i'm into compressing time so
i didn't read a book a day but i read
700 books in the area of human
development psychology physiology all of
my first real seven years of reading
right my youth in high school i was mr
solution you have a problem i have a
solution
especially if you're a girl i was
especially motivated i could really help
you with your boyfriend
you deserve to be loved even if you need
to do something for yourself
because real love doesn't have
conditions
real love takes joy when someone is
happy whatever it takes even if it means
being apart from you for a period of
time or even forever
otherwise it's not love
it's the selfish desire to get what you
want whether it makes someone else happy
or not
some of you are in relationships where
you're committed to the ship
and not the relations you're committed
to the institution and you forgot the
person
because you don't even meet the person
anymore you meet your story about the
person because you've told it to
yourself so many times so everything is
seen through that filter
if you think someone is your dear dear
friend and they're loving and they're
generous and they're a beautiful soul
and one day they treat you like [ __ ]
you'll be shocked and you'll be angry
and if you can't resolve it
and you have to leave to go deal with
something you'll generalize their
behavior later on you'll say they're
probably having a bad
what how many of you had a day where you
hope somebody generalized your behavior
is just a [ __ ] bad day
but if somebody you think that they
don't care
or they're selfish or they're mean
because you've generalized about the
human being
because by the way you can find
selfishness in anybody if you look for
it
including yourself whatever you look for
you're going to find you
can you find beauty can you find love
can you find generosity in any human
being yes or no
i had a moment like when my whole life
changed it was kind of twofold i had
i was i was really young like yourself
back then right working my tail off
trying to build a business i mean
big goals you know you don't always
succeed to start with right together
right you know it was hard
and i remember i was so frustrated
because i was working 18-hour days and
nothing was working and i was broke and
i felt embarrassed you know i should be
doing better than this
and so i was driving home from orange
county on the 57th freeway in san
gabriel valley out there placement in
pomona california and probably
not everybody else remembers so vividly
because it was almost midnight and i was
at this
breaking point and then i was like why
am i not you know
doing better and then i just pulled over
the road and i used to keep these
journals i still have them written
journals
and i wrote big lines you know the
secret to living is giving and i started
to cry
and i realized i am so focused on what
am i not getting
focusing on what i'm giving yeah so for
six months man it
turned me around but then you know
something else i get in your body it was
in my head it was in my heart but i had
to get
in there to stay and i started going
through some really tough times
and i lost everything financially and i
was mad at every because like i've
loaned a friend a thousand bucks and you
know i'm doing well and
he didn't even turn my phone call oh and
what changed me was
i i was down i don't know 22 23 bucks
something like that and it was 24
enough that i knew that i didn't have
money for food for the next week
and i didn't have any prospects and i
was living in venice in this 400 square
foot bachelor apartment feeling sorry
for myself
and i thought you know what i got to eat
so i'm not going to drive my car because
i'm not going to spend the gas i'm not
gonna pay for parking
sure i'm gonna go to an all-you-can-eat
place and load up for the winter right
so i can get more
like one meal a day right and so uh
there's a place called marina del rey
not far from venice
and it's beautiful community and it's
right on the water and there's a place
called el cerrito it's still there it's
a little
uh restaurant it had taco bar and all
that kind of stuff
so i walked there for the three miles
and i go like i'm gonna go and load up
and i was all about myself and getting
through this
and this little well this woman walked
the door actually very attractive lady
that's probably why i caught my dad
and i'm waiting to see who her boyfriend
is and there's nobody up there there's a
little guy down here
he was obviously her son and he's
wearing this three-piece suit you know a
little vest
he opens the door for he pulls out the
chair for her it was just
he stared at his mother's eyes i mean it
was just pierced into her eyes i
don't know what it was but something
about him was just so moving it was such
a
sweet caring loving young man to his
mother that moved me
so i i paid for my meal and always left
17 18 bucks
put it back in my pocket was left walked
up this young man introduced myself and
i said hi i don't understand what he
says his name is ronnie and it's ronnie
i said
since you're really i said you're a
class actor i saw you open the door for
your lady i saw you hold up the chair
for your lady goes she's my move
i said that's even more classy right
right and he's and i said so cool that
you're taking that to lunch like this
and he goes well i'm not really taking a
lunch because i'm just 11 and i don't
have a job you know i said yes you are
and i had no plan
literally just reached in my pocket took
all my head changed dollar pills and
threw it right there in front of him you
look at me like this he goes i can't
take that
i said sure you can he said well why i
said because i'm bigger than you
and he got this big grin in his face his
eyes got this big and i didn't i just
shook his hand i didn't even look at
this while his mom and i just walked out
the door but
the reason i tell the story is i had no
car i had no money
i did not i was euphoric i was like
flying home i'm just like you know i
look like
i was skipping or something and
what i thought was i should have been
like what did you just do i had no meal
when i was gonna eat
i went on that night i laid out a plan
and the plan was gonna take me you know
ten days two weeks so i thought well
people fast for a week i could fast for
a week that type of thing
and i was this great mindset about it i
woke up the next morning and i get the
old regular snail mail shows up
and it's this guy called a zillion times
it wouldn't return my call open it up
there's a check
thousand bucks plus interest and an
apology wow
so i'm sitting there and i started to
cry honestly and i was just like
why did this happen you know and i don't
know if it's true but i decided that day
this happened because i did the right
thing
because i didn't have a plan it wasn't a
strategy i just felt this
little soul beside me i knew it was
right and i did it and i didn't do it
because i thought
i could or i couldn't i didn't even
think about it and
that's the day i became a wealthy man
because i didn't have any money
but scarcity left my body and i had
plenty of ups and downs
since that time and various times in my
life but i never went back to that
oh my god you know how's it gonna happen
it's like breathing do you stop and say
god is there gonna be any air before you
take a breath you know it's gonna be
there right
you don't you don't run your life by
that aspect and so
that to me is what it's about is showing
people if you won't give a dime out of a
dollar
don't bite yourself you'll never give a
million out of 10 million or 10 million
out of 100 million
it's just not going to happen right but
if you can do that now you
you don't ever get beyond scarcity you
start behind it you you make a decision
to get beyond it but the next time
you're throwing a judgment on someone
else
remind yourself why you're doing it
you're doing it because you're uncertain
you're doing because you feel
insignificant
you're doing it for you feel
disconnected but you're the one making
yourself insignificant and uncertain
and disconnected because all that would
disappear if you entered their world and
tried to understand or appreciate
not understand intellectually that's why
if they appreciate
what they're going through doesn't mean
you have to agree with
it but if you appreciate it there'll be
compassion and where there's compassion
there is love
compassion means you care passionately
that's where it comes from not really
but i made it up it sounded good didn't
it it was really good
well if somebody is we're mentioning
earlier if somebody is really stressed
out
they're not stressed out for no reason
it's because they're focusing on
something that makes them feel stressed
they often when they're focusing on it
it changes the body you start to feel
tight you start to feel a certain way
and then they use language like i don't
know what to do why am i so overwhelmed
so three things control how you feel
every moment what you focus on
what you do with your body if your
shoulders are down if you're breathing
like ah
it's not hard to figure out you're not
going to be in a very resourceful state
if i take that same person and change
their body radically
i get to talk at a different tempo i get
them to move their body differently
i've taught this for what 41 years
three years ago at harvard they did a
study on power postures where they
showed that if you
stand like this with your hands on your
hips like superman or wonder woman
or if you lean back like this like the
guy isn't obnoxious at the office and do
this
it literally changes your testosterone
by 25
within two minutes it reduces cortisol
which you know is the stress hormone
by 30 and you're 33 more likely to take
an
action so if we change what we focus on
if we change the way we use our body if
we change our language patterns
we'll instantly feel different things
how do people use their body when
they're worried versus when they're
excited if you learn to use your body
first
use your focus first you can literally
change how you feel moments and then you
develop new habits where you start to
feel good all the time
and it isn't some phony fake pump up
it's literally the way you've
conditioned your body just like being
fit as an athlete you want to be
emotionally fit
there's no way that you're going to get
a secure environment the whole idea is
to build your money up build your assets
up
and eventually have the income take care
of you for the rest of your life the
only reason you invest is for income
income will buy you your trips it'll put
your kids through college they'll pay
for your home it'll give you food
people think they want assets assets can
go up and down for any period of time so
you want to put in a secure place at
some point
where the income provides all you need
for the rest of your life well
pretty hard to do that if you're putting
down an environment where you're trying
to get 10
it's not going to happen so you really
need 20 times your income that's really
the number that most people should be
utilizing
it doesn't sound very compelling but
when you understand compounding like
you know 300 a month for eight years
turns into 1.8 million ever put another
diamond you start to go
hmm maybe i can still win this game we
don't think geometrically
we think you know step at a time and the
way stocks work or the way any
investment works there's compounding and
the compounding is the greatest gift
that we have
my family was fed when i was 11 we had
no food at thanksgiving and
uh it touched me so deeply and i decided
i was going to get back so when i was
17 i fed two families and then four and
then eight and then i didn't tell me i
was doing it and then i got my friends
to do it and my companies grew and
you know i've had 42 million people now
over 37 years
and uh but you have a challenge for this
right well this one what i did is i
decided you know i'm writing this book
and in the middle of writing it
last summer most people don't even
notice congress cut food stamps they
don't call food stamps anymore but
i lived on them so i know what they are
food stamps my family family lived on
them
but they cut it by 8.7 billion which
means you eliminate 2 million people
from the rolls overnight and they still
need to eat
so i support all these non-profit
organizations and feeding america is the
largest in the country
and so i thought i want to call
attention to this so if i donated all
the profits in this book in advance how
many people could i feed because i
normally feed 2 million through my
foundation and i match it so i feed 4
million a year
and uh they said you could feed 10
million people i was like
wow i mean and then as the years gone by
i got more and more inspired and so now
i'm gonna feed
50 million people personally i'm not
just from the book i'm writing a larger
check on top of it
but also i'm working with feeding
america to get matching funds to meet
100 million people incredible so to go
from
my family not being able to eat to
feeding 100 million people is a
pretty amazing sense of gratitude and a
sense of grace and yeah i've done my
part but there's been grace in that as
well
the most common question i've been asked
by the media in my entire life that
always makes me laugh is
well don't you have bad days don't you
have days when you're like frustrated
anxiety and pissed off and
you watch tv and you eat cheetos and
watch pornography and i said well i do
some of those things right
and of course i do but when i it's like
an athlete i've built
muscle over the years so that it's not
that i don't have feelings i don't get
hurt i don't feel sad i don't feel tired
all those things but they're not the
dominant force in my life it's a muscle
the mind is a muscle emotion is a muscle
i mean i think the most powerful muscles
are the invisible force muscles it's
your spiritual emotional muscles like
courage unused doesn't grow it shrinks
so i put my ass on the line regularly so
that it grows and when it keeps growing
then pretty soon the stuff that used to
make me crazy
it doesn't touch me it's not that i'm so
great just i'm well trained i've trained
this mind
i get up every morning in my life you
can talk about rebounder more crazy that
ideas everywhere in my life if i'm near
if i'm near any of my homes and some
places i
have i have cryotherapy but my homes i
have these cold plungers
and they're 56 degrees and the first
thing i do is jump in that cold point so
there's not a
morning where i want to jump in that i
can't remember mine's like i can't wait
to jump in that thing
but i don't negotiate with myself i do
it for two reasons one there's a
physical health component it moves your
lymph system and
the blood flushes through your whole
body but the main reason i do it even
more than that
is when i go up there i don't you know
people negotiate well i'm able to do it
tomorrow i'm going to do this or i'll
let me like two more minutes until i'm
ready
there's none of it with me for decades i
go i say
we do i'm not here to discuss with my
mind
there's mind and then there's soul and
spirit and soul and spirit my soul
knows and when i say jump you can jump
i'm not here to have a discussion with
you
i always tell people uh anticipation is
power if you ever play a video game
against a child it's pretty disastrous
right maybe not for you you're maybe a
different generation but for me it's
like you know it's not the kids faster
and smarter
if they played this game before like
eight million times so they know the
first shots here the second shot
third shot there and you're like
reacting so when you're reacting to
things you fail so
my mentors have been people over the
years different people my earliest
mentor was a man named jim rohn he was a
personal development speaker just
touched my life
then i was involved in neuro-linguistic
programming nlp when i was
21 22 23 years old i became partners
with a man named john grinder
brilliant man co-founder of that but in
my last
couple decades it's been people like
peter guber who's owns the the la
dodgers and
and owns uh you know the golden state
warriors nba team and he's
just got 52 academy award nominations so
he's a
mentor for me um a paul tutor jones i
coach but also i'm coached by him
because
we get to pitch and catch um and then
you know i've got some people in my life
that
you know like steve wynn is a dear
friend of mine most of las vegas he's
brilliant and these guys are all 18
years my senior
so they know the road ahead and i'm able
to learn from them in advance and
kind of anticipate things and that to me
is incredibly valuable yeah very cool
what is the one thing that you want
people to understand about control when
they feel out of control they feel they
don't understand the stock market like
what's the one message you wanna you
want people to take home around control
i think it's uh that you have to become
an owner and not just a consumer
you have to take a percentage of what
you earn as simplistic as it sounds
and automate it so it comes off the top
of what you earn uh there's a gentleman
that used work for ups
names theodore and theodore robinson was
this guy who
never made more than fourteen thousand
dollars a year
and yet he retired with 70 million
dollars and gave away 35 million while
he's alive how did he do it
he became an owner his best friend said
to him listen to me the most important
thing in your life is we're going to put
a wealth tax on you because your wealth
tax
i think 14 000 a year he goes we're
going to make you wealthy with this tax
it's not a government taxes tax for
yourself
so we're going to take 20 of what you
earn and put in an investment account
let it build up
he said i can't afford that he goes once
it's automated you won't notice
that's all he did that made him 70
million dollars so it's like people have
to understand that no matter how good
you are in business
we all need a second business with no
employees and it takes very little time
something that once you do your homework
should take you you know 15 minutes to
an hour twice a year to rebalance
perhaps
but outside of that that's what this is
this is setting up a business that will
make you do well
when i was um when i was 20 24 years old
25 years old i worked with a man named
ken blanchard who wrote
those one-minute manager books you
probably remember him evan yeah
really great guy and he i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game and
that made me god to him so
and then he said i want to return the
favor and he goes the best advice i got
growing my business was i was about to
come out with my first book
and he said a friend of mine who's very
wealthy said do not put that money in
your company let the leads go to your
company do not let the profits go and do
not spend those profits
put that in a separate account that
nothing ever touches because your
business will eat whatever resources you
have what a growing business does that
and he said tony i put that aside and
during the tough times that's what made
me safe well i did the same thing with
that in my original infomercials
that alone made me a wealthy man so when
tough times came
i could withstand it so i see so many
business owners go yeah but i have
control of my business
you have influence over your business
yes you have more influence but there
are better entrepreneurs than you
perhaps out there as well or
businesses that get greater valuations
in your business will
and so your ability to grow you want to
grow your own business i always tell
people
you want to build two businesses the
business you're in in the business
you're becoming
and you want to have the business that
you're in and becoming an investment
business
it's really simple once you set it up
and i think everybody's got to do that
if they really want to have financial
freedom because
look the marketplace changes competition
changes ibm was the head of the pack
forever and then some little kid from
microsoft comes along
and buys ms-dos for fifty thousand
dollars and then
leases it to them and makes himself
three billion on that little move alone
he didn't even write their software
right you know he's doing great and all
of a sudden you know this little company
comes along a couple of guys at stanford
called google
you know and apple comes along so
there's always disruption and the
disruption can be competition it can be
new technology it could be a change in
the culture so even if you do everything
right
you could lose i want people to have a
back-up plan this is the back-up plan
why is lebron james who he is it's not
because he's lucky
in other words say you know he's lucky
he might have certain physical tackles
or michael jordan i remember i
interviewed him years ago
and i said what makes you the best in
the world is it skill is it talent is it
ability is it backward is it training
and he was so awesome he said tony i can
tell you the truth and it won't sound
like hyperbole or false modesty
he said i didn't even make the high
school basketball team
my sophomore year i was cut he said what
it is is every day i demand more for
myself than anybody else could possibly
expect i don't
compete with other people i compete with
what i'm capable of
and there's just like that kind of
standard is inspiring if you
need this whole business about meeting
your needs you can run a successful
business but it'll be a job
because you'll never be able to sell it
because it's just meeting your needs
it's not a system it demands your
attention or your connection
it's giving what you want but ultimately
it's not going to give somebody else
what they want so you can't sell it if
you can't sell your business if you
don't have an exit strategy
you have a job i don't care how
successful the business is
that doesn't mean you have to sell the
business but one of the most important
decisions you make in business is
ultimately if i was going to sell this
if i chose to
i have to know who would i sell this to
so that i have long term value not just
in income along the way
i have this critical mass here i get a
multiple of my business
and most people don't have a clear exit
strategy they think i'll come up with
that someday
you're going to start with that end in
mind that's got to be part of your focus
if you're going to be successful in your
business
i can remember a gentleman who's built
caa in hollywood as the largest most
successful agency
right michael ovitz remember that name
he put together nike and coca-cola and
these billion dollar deals
and eventually mike obits went to go
sell that business he never thought
through an exit strategy and he got
almost nothing for it
because the laws prevented him from
selling it to a studio
he had to sell to some of his employees
for pennies on its real value
now mike found a way to make money later
on in another place off of disney
but the bottom line is the guy didn't
have an exit strategy and there was
brilliant made lots of money in the end
didn't get the value
breakdowns it's certainly not something
i experienced but it's not because i'm
so talented or so brilliant or so
fearless it's just
you're like an athlete you're an athlete
yeah you're in shape yeah right
you're not gonna have a reaction in your
body like somebody who doesn't take care
of themselves right
so you know i believe i don't believe in
emotional intelligence i think it's
useful but i'm more interested in
emotional fitness
because intelligence is a capability
fitness is a state of readiness
interesting
if you are fit you can take that demand
right now
you can deal with it you can deal with
that physical stress that emotional
stress same is true with psychological
fitness emotional fitness right so i'm
pretty fit
and part of that is not because i'm so
smart part of this i i've taught this
for decades i remember i had a woman who
came on my seminars in
the early 80s probably and she would run
in this room five ten thousand people i
think was you know two in a couple of
ten thousand person events
and she would get in this front row and
find her way through there and she'd
jump and go for it and one break she
came up to
signing a book for her and she says she
goes mrams i've seen you at like eight
of these
i've seen you like when you're really i
know i can hear your voice
you're hurting or you haven't slept and
she goes you always seem to be so up all
the time how come you're so up and i
said well part because i attend all
these seminars yeah yeah
so i'm teaching it so there's a fitness
of that there's also
you know i've i've buried three fathers
and one mother
and you know that affects your life i've
uh you know i've had a
physician look me in the eye and say you
have a tumor in your brain wow and so
i've had those moments that
when you've had extreme stress and you
push your way through it
you build psychological muscle it's like
it takes a lot to knock me off you know
in the early days
we didn't have fifty thousand dollars
keep the doors open how do we do it then
i had you know graduated to five million
that i graduated to
uh a partner that mine who kind of
didn't do things well and i
ended up owning a hundred million
dollars because i had to take on his
debts 100 million dollars
and but when you do all that stuff you
know now my companies do five billion
you know a year so
uh well you you keep expanding what i
would call
really the circle of your the threshold
of your influence sure
you know everybody has a threshold of
control and if you get beyond it you
kind of freak out so
it takes a little bit more i don't know
breakdowns it's not a breakdown
do i get pissed off or get frustrated or
tired yeah but
break down honestly no what would you
tell the startup entrepreneur
who maybe is just getting started or
maybe still has a full-time job and
it feels like every dollar that they're
making they're just trying to build
their business at the moment
they haven't cashed out yet should they
be invested into their business should
they still be saving someone put into
the market what would you tell that
person
i think you have to put something
outside your business because what's the
number one rule of investing that even
understand don't pull all your eggs in
one basket right and what did 90
of entrepreneurs do because of the
illusion of control
they go i'm going to put all my money in
my business don't get me wrong it's
still a great place for your money and
for your time with your energy
but you got to take a piece of what you
earn and you got to bet on some other
entrepreneurs and get outside yourself
specifically
and if you look at you know somebody
like warren buffett will tell you you
know look
he said my all my wealth is a result of
a couple things some good genes
and compound interest and living in
america so
if all you do is get compound interest
on your side the game changes you take a
19 year old kid
that's got a little job and you say look
i want you it sounds like a lot but i
want you to put aside 300
a month let me show you why 300 bucks a
month set aside
thrown in the market average market
return has been eight percent it's been
10
of 100 years but most recent you know 30
years eight percent
so let's say you get the average return
and it compounds
that kid who starts at 19 with 300 a
month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 000
but that'll grow to 1.8 million without
putting another diamond that's the power
of compounding 28 grand 1.8 million
if his best friend starts at 27 when he
quits and invests every single year all
the way to 65
and he puts in the same 300 a month he
puts in 140 grand
and at that time he's got 400 000 less
money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're going to win
and you need to get in the game now
i live my life where i keep learning i
keep growing i keep loving i keep
laughing
and i'm trying to leave a decent legacy
of a meaningful life
by constantly looking for ways that i
can be helpful and my prayer
my simple prayer before i walk out on
every stage is use me use me lord and
and when you do that it's like if you
get out of the way my greatest gift is
getting out of the way
i know that sounds silly to some people
but it's really true i'm not an ultra
religious person
but i'm extremely spiritual and i
believe the force of life comes through
me it comes through you comes through
all of us and the only thing gets in the
way
is all the beliefs we have how it's
supposed to be all the expectations we
have and i have them too
but i keep weeding them out sir john
templeton is probably one of the
greatest investors in history
people don't know his name uh he started
out with nothing
um he wasn't sir he wasn't from the
country came from the us
and he decided that he wanted to
understand wealth and so he saved ten
thousand dollars a huge amount of money
in those days
and when hitler invaded poland he
developed a belief
his belief was you make your money in
times of maximum pessimism
like if you were around a 2008 nine you
remember what was like right
you could have bought you know the sands
in las vegas you could have bought their
stock for two dollars and 28 cents today
at 67
wow it's a 3 000 return not bad um you
could have bought
uh citibank for less than a buck right
so people in those times he understood
that and so what he did was that
everybody thought the world was going to
end
he took ten thousand dollars he bought
every stock on new york stock exchange
it was a dollar or less including
companies everybody thought we're going
bankrupt
but we when things are bad people think
it's gonna be bad forever when things
are good they think it's gonna be good
forever and they're always wrong life's
cyclical
so there's a season for everything so
once we got through world war ii and a
few years later
guess what those same stocks made him a
billionaire so when i asked him i said
what's the secret to wealth
his responsibility touched me goes you
know it you teach it i said what's that
he said gratitude
and so why do you say that he said
because if you got a billion dollars and
every day you live
pissed off and frustrated the quality of
your life is called pissed off and
frustrated right
but if you have nothing but you're
euphorically grateful for whatever you
have
you're the richest person that you're
gonna know he said so it doesn't matter
how much money you got if you don't have
gratitude so i do the same thing by the
way i have a process i call priming
where i get up every morning i do mine
in the morning
i just radical change to my body kind of
alter my state
and then i do 10 minutes i never miss
and my first three and a half minutes is
what i'm really grateful for and i make
myself think of at least one of those
three that's something
really simplistic yeah something giant
you know the wind on my face the look in
one of my
kids eyes you know something of that
nature and then i do three minutes of
strengthening healing and i do three
minutes of what i'm going to create my
world and i do that for a minimum of 10
minutes every day because i believe
you have to condition you don't just
hope that stuff shows up you set your
intention each morning
every day yeah i look at control as a
delusion
right that's the first thing it's your
desire for the illusion of control
that's pushing you
what you want is certainty you want
certain you can avoid pain you want
certain you can have pleasure you want
certainty you can have a significant and
meaningful life we all want certainty
but uh learning ways to control what you
can control is wonderful but you can't
control
most things what you can do is influence
them and so what i look at and say is
don't give myself the delusion i have
control
because then i'll feel like i've lost it
at some point i never had control i have
influence i can influence my kids i
can't control them i can influence
myself i can
influence what happens to me financially
can't control it completely
and so i think if you give up the
illusion of control that loosens things
up a little bit but i think the second
thing
is to focus on what you can control
which is what what you think feel and
what you do
and if i focus on the things i can
control i want to feel better i mean all
the research shows
that human beings when they feel out of
control freak out inside
and the more they feel they're in
control the greater their self-esteem
the way to have that additional control
is to say okay what i can control is
what i do within the seasons
you can say i don't like gravity and
step off the side here but you're going
to pay the price
there are certain things that are
outside your control but you can use
gravity i fly a helicopter an airplane
because i understand the dynamics of how
to do that
if you understand the dynamics of the
marketplace you use the marketplace the
marketplace doesn't use you
and that's why i wrote unshakeable i
want people to have no more fear
and when you start understanding some of
these statistics like
what's everybody afraid of a bear market
a bear market is when it you know
market cracks 20 or more over the last
80 years they've happened about every
three to five years to give you an idea
later years more five years well now
we've gone
the longest period in history without
one and yet people are still afraid
after every single bear market we've had
in the history of the united states it's
led immediately into a bull market if
you remember 2008 2009
50 drop in the next 12 months it was up
the s p was up 69 it's almost 70
i can show you every turn down so when
you start seeing that it's
it's immutable it's like winter comes
but winter isn't forever
and winter is a great time to take
advantage because some people freeze the
death in winter other people ski and
snowboard and get by the fire
well winter is when things are on sale
if somebody said to you i got a 400 000
ferrari that you could buy for
seventy thousand dollars you're probably
grabbing a heartbeat but if somebody
takes you a stock that was four hundred
dollars and seventy bucks you're like oh
my god i can't do this
you have to look at the cycles of
history and when you do it you become
unshakable and more importantly you
become wealthy
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate
and i think meditation is wonderful but
i haven't met many people that can not
think thoughts
this is a different outcome this is
about priming yourself it's about
putting yourself in a state where your
mind and body will respond
accordingly we'll do three steps it's
really simple over 10 minutes so
why don't you sit down and i'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable
you want to be sitting up is that back
enough for you to be able to relax yeah
good
okay cool and then the first thing
you're going to do is your hands are
going to come
up as you take the breath in and then
you're going to explode out the nose
down explosive that's it
good that's it keep going two more
[Music]
good now relax keep your eyes closed
have your hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that
just feel whatever you feel just take it
in and you don't have to respond to me
anymore you just enjoy it and take it in
and now just let your body relax deeply
and i'd like you to begin to think of a
moment in your life you could feel
really grateful for if you wanted to it
could be something little rich or could
be something big it doesn't matter it
could be from your childhood or
this week it doesn't matter do your best
to remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping in your body and seeing
what you saw then
through your own eyes hearing what you
heard then feeling what you felt then
[Music]
just savor it maximize that sense of
appreciation or enjoyment
or gratitude enjoy it
feel it fill up with it and now we're
going to shift to the last piece really
simple all you're going to do is focus
on three things one at a time that you
want to accomplish
three things you want to achieve live it
and feel it and experience it
how was that it was good yeah what'd you
feel
refreshing yeah it's good to like escape
inside myself yeah there's two worlds to
master the external world in the
internal world they both have to be
bastard but if you
master the external world you know i'll
uh you know
robin williams but you don't master the
internal world there's a big price
this is the one to master first and so i
start my day by making that so i have
this base
to do it i'm going to live from
gratitude today i'm going to live from
blessing you know i want to be a
blessing in people's life today i'm
going to get stronger today and i'm
going to achieve what i'm here committed
to do
and in the whole thing you know we did
that one in a little less than 10
minutes to give you an idea
i believe that leadership is really a
skill of influence
it is the most important skill that any
human being can master and i don't think
of leadership as
a position i see it as a skill a tool
that all of us have to have
in other words the quality of your life
i really believe comes down to your
level of leadership other people don't
have to follow you to be a leader
but you have to live life on your terms
and the first person you have to
influence is yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are
you know on drugs or not is who has more
influence the guy on the street corner
or you
with your fit or fat is can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary
so i think to be able to influence
the thoughts the feelings the emotions
and the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is i believe in
work-life integration
i don't think um uh and i'm not being
disrespectful because
oh no no yeah i want to hear that's what
i'm saying everybody has a different
metaphor i'm telling you my metaphor
i'm not making somebody wrong who's
focused on balance but to me if you say
balance it's like okay let's use a
teeter-totter or a see-saw
okay we're gonna let's balance it now
now that we've done that
how long are we gonna stand there
balancing this thing before one of us
wants to jerk this thing around just to
feel alive
right yeah so i really think balance is
is more about integration for me it's
more about
um like how do i make sure that i feel
like the areas of my life
my wife my children my grandchildren my
health
sports i got 31 companies you got 1200
employees and seven radically different
industries we do
five billion a year i mean it's so if
all these things are going on
how do i do that well i believe that the
way i do that is in streaks i do streaks
of unbelievable intensity work and i do
streaks of like
let go and be in you know paradise and
enjoy
and so i like running hot i want to i
want to be and have me climb a new
mountain that's just me
so i'm not saying that's right for other
people i'm saying you got to find what
it is but the idea of balance for most
people makes them torture themselves
and i say for me if it tortures you get
rid of it
instead of saying talk about immigration
i asked mary callahan erdos
who's if you're not familiar with her
she's probably the
one of if not the smartest person in the
financial world
female she's uh head of jp morgan and
manages 2.3 trillion with the t that'll
be
trillion dollars of the money one of the
nicest human beings ever meet
breaks all the molds on people in the
financial business there's not an ounce
of manipulation in your body
i mean just good good soul and i asked
her about the balancing
one of the biggest bank in the world
right trillions of dollars
and she said tony i don't believe in it
and she told me work life balanced our
life we're completing each other's
sentences she has the same philosophy
but her dad used to take her to work and
he was a financial guy when she was a
little girl
she used to have her brother be the
secretary she took her dad's seat and
ran the show
and she said doing that with my dad she
goes i loved it i was a part of his life
i got to be a part of see that part of
his life it's been coming home and
me not knowing it and she said that's
what she's done with her kids and at jp
morgan she leaves and picks her kids up
and she still runs the biggest bank in
the world and builds trillions of
dollars so
would she say it's balanced she'd say no
it's not balanced it's integrated
she knows when to move into one or the
other right so that all the parts of her
life are rich maybe instead of balance
it's
a rich life in the areas that matter
yeah right rich with your children
rich with your husband or wife rich with
your dear friends
rich with the impact that you want to
have your mission rich in terms of
successful business and
or whatever your career is that you
really feel a sense of meaning and
enjoyment
to me that's more important than balance
and i think but i'm a very passionate
crazy son
so it's like you know balance sounds a
little boring to me first
if you're tortured by balance trying to
be balanced like other people i'm not
balanced enough
give it up instead enjoy yourself
enjoy your children enjoy the time be
where you are right now
that to me is more important than trying
to make everything balanced because that
becomes that gets you cerebral it makes
you evaluate things the more you
evaluate
the less you can actually experience
what's here right now right everything
in my world is based on coming up with
the outcome that will serve
and then going at it but most the time
your approach going at it doesn't work
no one else knows that but you know you
can see it doesn't work so it's
constantly changing your approach until
you can get where you want to go when i
enter an audience and i'm
going to give a talk of any sort i do a
huge amount of homework in advance i
prepare i see he was there
but then when i stand up here i wouldn't
be sitting like this i'm scanning
constantly who i'm looking for other
people think
i'm going after the people who got
dragged there i'm not looking for the
people clapping for me you know
those people will always be there and
there's some people clap even if you're
terrible so you don't want to let other
people's view
make you feel good i'm looking for who
isn't there so that i can reach them
so i can show them that there's
something real here because you know
most people
don't know who i am they'd see you know
ten thousand people jumping in a stadium
and they go it's just a big motivational
pump up i've never been a motivator it's
never
been about what i've been about i think
motivation's useful it's like a warm
bath you should probably take a bath or
a shower every day
but you need more than that you need
strategy and i but what i really believe
is the energy
most of us grew up and right now most of
you are learning and the traditional
style you did even when you're in school
you were trained to go to your seat and
be silent
and be polite and nice but the world we
live in today isn't like that the world
today
if somebody sits down and waits for
someone to tell them what to do they're
in trouble so
my approach is constantly stimulating
and seeing what's real getting people to
be raw
and getting to truth you know as corny
as it is the truth sets us free and we
all can find our own truth
um as long as we put ourselves an
environment where we don't tolerate
anything less than that
michael gerber the guy that wrote the
e-myth you know talks about why so many
businesses
young businesses fail and one of these
things he says is most people
are not really entrepreneurs but they
think that's what they should be
they think that's the sexy thing that's
the most attractive thing that's
the best answer and what i say to you is
you got to separate the vehicle
from the outcome what is it that's going
to truly fulfill you what is it that's
going to give you that extraordinary
life
what's going to make things magnificent
on your terms not somebody else's terms
not your father your mother your
background
what is that really separate the
vehicles there's many ways to get that
vehicle
but i'm saying sometimes you got to
reevaluate what's going to really make
you fulfill
what is your gift are you an artist are
you the talent
can produce something no one else
produces as a skill or a product or a
service
or some impact are you incredibly good
at management
you really know how to manage or lead
people are you an extraordinary
entrepreneur that has
can take that gigantic gut load of risk
and can create the vision and attract
the talent that you need and the
managers and leaders
you may have all three abilities but
which one really fulfills you the most
is going to be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
especially room like this because you're
all over achievers right me too
and you say well i can do all these yes
you can but what will it do
to your quality of life see again the
secret's going to be this
what is an extraordinary life on your
terms today
treat people at the end of the
relationship like it's the beginning
and there won't be an end and that's not
just your intimate relationship
what if your customers what if you fell
in love with your customers with your
clients
more than your product more than your
company
if your entire life is about meeting
their needs if you would do what for
your customers clients you would do what
if you love your customers and clients
you do anything guess what they're gonna
love you
but most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want
respond to them and when they don't they
go that's the end
you want clients for life not just
customers fall in love with them
it's a different focus isn't it it's a
different meaning
and that creates a different life
because you make decisions differently
from that place
leverage is critical you know i get so
much done
because i don't just get it done i know
the outcome i know the purpose
and i look for leverage leverage is
different than delegation
what's problem with delegation
delegation is you have all that needs to
be done so you give it to someone else
and you tell them needs to be done and
when they don't do it you're pissed off
leverage says i can move the biggest
boulder in the world with a little bit
of effort
if i get something i can do it with
but i'm still part of it so leverage is
if i'm going to leverage something here
with tom
i'm going to make sure tom understands
the what the outcome
i want to make sure tom understands the
the purpose the why
and the action but i might say to tom if
you can get this done without this
action or better action go for it baby
and i want to talk to you on this date
and we gotta promise and we're gonna
check in before it's needed
so there's no surprises if you're having
problems tom come back to me because
we're partners on this
that i call leverage different than
delegation and you know what i do when i
have no time there is time i just got to
leverage it
i'm saying say i have no one to leverage
it to you know shane over here right
like all the stuff he wants to do can't
leverage it but shane's answer was
hire somebody then he thinks about what
it's going to take and goes 125 000
i can't do that now he's getting caught
up in one way to get the outcome
leverage he goes through his list and
goes what if i got somebody to do 20
of this stuff i got i could spend 20
grand to get that much freedom i could
pay four times 10.
and if i'm really productive my
productivity should enhance the world
not only my clients and customers
but it should provide jobs for other
people and if there's anything you hate
to do it's because you're either
ineffective at it or you don't think
it's very important but it is urgent
so you need to hire somebody for those
things and ideally somebody who loves
that job you're never going to grow when
your time is eating up for activities
that aren't that important activity
without high levels of purpose is the
drain of your fortune
do it now if you can't get it all now do
a part of it now
leverage is power leverages ultimate
power
here's what i've created for my life and
anyone who knows succeeded
i'm a 17 year old kid from azusa
california
with no real education other than
self-education
with no background with parents that did
their best
all of them
with no money but i did one thing i love
people
and i had an enormous demand i made upon
myself and i
sculpted my mind and my emotions to get
me to do whatever it would take to
achieve
and to contribute but to do that i did
it by using my body and changing my
focus
i did it by putting myself in a peak
physiology and using what i call
incantations can you train yourself to
believe something yes or no
absolutely how many have you ever made
the fatal mistake of going to disneyland
or disney world
and while you're there made the fatal
mistake of going to a ride called it's a
small world after all
what happens for about a week after
you're out of that damn place
you're still singing this thing in your
head in 24 languages right
well let me tell you something how many
of you have things when you want to
achieve them and this part of your voice
goes oh it's not gonna happen or forget
it
i'm gonna go to voice that sometimes
interrupts that good pattern say i
what you want to do is train a new one
so starting when i was 17 i started
doing incantations
not affirmations affirmation you go i'm
happy i'm happy i'm happy i'm happy i'm
happy
what's the problem you haven't changed
your what you're what
physiology if you don't change your
physiology you won't get anything so an
incantation is the only you speak it
but you embody what you're saying with
all the intensity you can
and you do it with enough repetitions
that it sticks in your head like it's a
small world now the conversation your
head is always the same and it gives you
what you want
so use your body and your voice so
17 years ago i started doing things i
was working for jim rohn this
speaker and i was 17 years old i had
long hair minestrone soup acne on my
face
i was trying to call on bear stearns
type of people and convince them why
they should go to this man's seminar be
more successful
i was driving 1968 volkswagen that i had
earned at 40
a week as a janitor the only way i did
it was park
far from the building and then go in and
i love people i believe when i put
myself in
state and i was able to influence people
that were far more successful than i was
at the time
i would do something that i still do
backstage and i've done for
23 years because i don't hope i'm going
to be in a good state i demand it
so i do an incantation using my whole
body i'd say i now command my
subconscious mind
to direct me in helping as many people's
possible life today to
better their lives by giving me the
strength the emotion the persuasion the
humor the brevity whatever it takes
to show these people and get these
people to change their lives now
and i would do that literally driving in
my volkswagen to a meeting
in l.a on the freeway for 40 minutes
people are looking i'm screaming at my
lungs
they're going i know he's a serial
killer i know he is
by the time i entered that room when two
people meet
if there's rapport the person who's most
certain will always influence the other
person
and i was totally certain and they were
trying to get revved up to certainty
do you agree with this yes or no i do
another one because i was poor i changed
my mindset
i kept doing things but i never got
beyond it i'd say god's wealth is
circulating in my life as well flows to
me and avalanches of abundance
all my needs desires and goals are met
instantaneously by
infinite intelligence where i'm one with
god and god is everything
and i would imagine the abundance of my
life and i would feel so grateful
and a year later i went for making 38
000 a year to make a million dollars a
year in one year
you really have to decide the most
important decision is do i want to be
happy
will i commit to being happy more
importantly than happy
sometimes you'd be so happy you smile so
much your face hurts right you need
variety
am i committed to living in a beautiful
state even when it doesn't go my way
even when it rains on my parade
even when my biggest fear shows up
because i can't control
whether your husband or wife will live
or die or get sick or leave you or get a
divorce i don't want any of that to
happen any human being i hate suffering
i do anything i can help people not
suffer
but i can't control that you can you can
there are people have lost their arms
lost their sight there have been people
that have been through the most horrific
experiences in life and they found a way
to still be happy because they've made
the decision that life is too short to
suffer
i've interviewed dozens and hundreds
over the years but dozens that like have
impacted my soul
that made me realize i can change this
i've just gotten used to it i bought
into the theory that this
this survival software that's constantly
running
and making you suffer that that's normal
no that's
what the mind will do and mind has been
around forever
what i'm going to do is something
different and the way i get out of
suffering
i give myself a 90 second rule it's
really simple i say look
if i feel myself starting to feel that
stress feeling that pissed offness or
upsetness or concern or worry about my
kid whatever
i realize that's not going to make it
better life's too short to suffer
and then i just kind of breathe slowly
slow everything down
and i just watch the thought go by and
go look at that crazy thoughts everybody
said crazy thoughts everybody says i
thought i'm going to kill that son of a
try and then you don't kill them because
you don't believe that thought
it's the thoughts that are stressful
that you believe that mess you up
when you question them you break the
pattern the more i've done it's like a
muscle
the more i've trained myself to do it i
can authentically tell you now it takes
a lot for something to take more than 90
seconds for me now and the
level of joy surpasses all the money you
could ever have in a million years and
then
the money it's easier to make money
because you're not attached you don't
have the fears you don't have the
scarcity that people have because you
feel so rich already
right now i always tell people don't
wait to be rich what is that richness
it's abundance it's joy it's happiness
it's contribution
it's getting out of yourself because as
long as we're thinking about
oh my god i lost something or you did
something
i have less love less respect less money
if i think
loss less or because you did something
or because i did something i'm
never gonna have what i want in my life
lost less than ever those three
thought patterns they're the source of
all suffering most people
who start a business very often will
start two and three four
more and the reason they do it is
because the first one isn't succeeding
or they're no longer
patient that's exactly right and so what
happens that person is they're never
going to be successful in most cases
unless they get lucky
bounce across something that's easier to
do but most people are always looking
for
that next level what my view is is it's
great to test all these things but
you've got to find what is your
flagship what is it that you're going to
commit your soul to
because if you don't do that the
inevitable challenge are going to come
up and you're going to then move on to
something 100
enjoyable and so the other thing to look
at is business is about
constantly not only adding such massive
value doing more further as anybody else
but it's also simultaneously
about your own psychology it's your
ability to go through thresholds of
control
um it's like i can remember when i
didn't have 50 000
to keep the doors open on my company i
had 12 employees and 11 wanted to quit
because they hated the person running
the show
and 50 000 would be like 500 million to
me today and i figured out how to get
through that threshold and once i did
like all the problems related that were
handled i know you've done this as well
and then i you know i had a five million
dollar lawsuit was totally unfair and
unjust
and i finally had just the amount of
time energy and learning how to bite the
bullet and do it five million was more
than i could remember they made a
partner
who took a company losing a million
dollars a day and turned into 1.5
billion in positive ebitda
i'm not mentioning names amway and
he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners not doing the
multi-level side
did the business put in 10 million bucks
we all put in 10 million 40 million in
debt
but i signed joint and several which i
didn't understand in those days what
that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke
we bought some more companies i end up
with 120 million dollars in debt that i
was on the hook for no one else had any
money
and i'm getting up to do a seminar
wanting to throw up there's a new
threshold of control so you know when
you ski or you snowboard
and you think you're maybe you're just
new at it and you think you're going
down a blue or green it turns out to be
a double black
and you're like yeah and so you have two
choices
one is you start to go down and you
freak out you're going to die slam on
the ground try to hang on for dear life
or the other is baby you focus on where
you want to go
you find a way and once you do it a
couple of times
you get used to it you have no more fear
of that element now my biggest one
out of that that led me to a billion i
have 31 companies now to give you an
idea
seven different industries as diverse as
like uh
you know stem cells to virtual reality
with the exclusive the nba now virtually
out to give an example
we do i got 1200 employees we're on
three continents
and we got five billion dollars in sales
but i did that because i first stayed on
one freaking yeah
i'm so masterful at it there is another
level
the only reason you keep saying there
isn't is you feel so exhausted about
where you are
but life the universe or god is just
testing you
because there is another level if this
is good giant jump to excellence
giant start good poor to good to
excellence
there's a level where all your dreams
are realized
there's a level that you've always
dreamed about it is real it has not gone
away
but it takes that extra burst when you
think there's nothing left
there's no way you've tried everything
10 million times
and you keep going it's almost like god
is saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times i will see that you will
not stop that you are filled with that
level of determination
faith and courage and then the door
opens and you get to that next level but
most people don't know is
the next level is just two millimeters
above
and it's called outstanding ladies and
gentlemen outstanding
what's it called what's it called
what's it called outstanding magnificent
unstoppable extraordinary not excellent
it's a different level it's a level
where
you are not one of the best you are the
best
you know what's amazing you only have to
be two millimeters more than everybody
else and you get everything you get the
joy the laughter the fun the family
the passion the economics the freedom
the spirit it's all there
what jerry maguire called the quan baby
all of it and it's just two millimeters
above
and most excellent people give up
because they're exhausted and there's
some people to go
the harder i hit it the more i hit it
sooner or later
it's going down i'm not stopping and
when you do that enough it pops open
failure is part of life i mean the
difference for me though is i look at
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump i know i'm gonna fail
um but it's not failure if you learn
something and so
gosh i've made so many mistakes i've
screwed so many things up but
every time i do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes
you know it's like here's what i've done
i think i have the ability to influence
people because i talk about my failures
i talk about
all the things that mess me up but i
show people that i didn't let it stop me
and you don't let it stop you and i
think
i think that's really the secret that
area and if everything you touched was
successful
i was gonna relate to people as much no
you'll be related and also to be told
everyone knows and also you'd be bored
silly
i mean think about it if you just said i
want this to happen i want this and it
happened
you know people don't value what they
don't fight for you know it's like you
see kids sometimes in it you know your
parents will say you're not going to
value this if you don't work for it
and you're a kid to go on oh value just
give it to me right but it's true
you know the things we've worked the
hardest for we value the most
so i think you know the purpose of a
goal is not getting it anyway the
purpose of goal you know is what who you
become
who you become is going to make you
happy or who's going to make you sad so
um
i'm not looking for an effortless
approach there's no such thing
one of the critics actually that i once
met said yeah tony's techniques they
were great for about a year and a half
and then they wore
off what do you say to that photo
it's real simple if you don't work out
you don't get you don't get a muscle
right so i always tell people this is
there's a daily practice like priming if
you don't do that if you get up and you
just
have no discipline whatsoever you get no
value of anything your diets don't work
when you don't do them exercise doesn't
work when you don't do them but
most people have some experiences that
they want to shift
and once you shift those things your
whole life changes but life is constant
growth
my life isn't here because i went to one
seminar one time and now my life is
fit for life i i work out i train my
mind i train my body
it becomes a lifestyle it's not just
like you're depending upon somebody else
i'm not here to become somebody's guru
i'm not here to give them a gift i'm
here them to open up their own gifts and
that's really what my work has been
the only way to deal with fear that i
found in my life is a couple ways
one of those ways is to turn it on
itself and ask yourself
what am i afraid of i'm afraid of that i
got to be more afraid of
what i'm going to miss out on missing
out on my mission missing out on who i'm
supposed to be missing
in other words if you're not going to
get rid of fear then use fear
use fear or it uses you it's that simple
so you gotta say okay what's the price
if i just stay doing this what's the
price
what i need to really get scared if i
learn all this and i don't follow
through
that's something to be scared about and
then that fear will get you
over your fear it'll push you through
turn fear in itself
second way you can do it is use what
you've probably heard me say because
i've used it so i was 17
is my little rocking chair test right
i'm gonna i'm gonna sit myself in my
rocking chair i'm i'm 85 years old and
looking back on my
life and i say i didn't do this or i did
if you find your passion you're going to
have this tremendous energy it's
sustainable energy
but momentum requires you always do the
next thing to keep the momentum going
and the reason you get yourself in a
passionate place
is so that you change your life and the
only thing that changes your life is
making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you're like
i don't know what do you think all right
let's decide
if you make a decision in a state
without momentum if you make a decision
from a place
where there's no passion you are not
going to get momentum it'll
kill momentum it's decide commit
and resolve some of you
in the past you've gotten momentum
you've gotten passionate
you've even made a decision but
a decision is the first step decision is
like a war
i gotta do this or that all right i'm
gonna make myself do this
but commitment is when you now
after you've decided you commit to do
this for the long term whether it's hard
or easy doesn't matter
you're doing this it takes it from this
moment
and it carries you to the future even
when things are difficult
and the third state is resolve
resolve means it's done
it's like it doesn't even if you took
action it's done inside you
so it's done out there there's no
question whatsoever
then once you decide the only way the
commitment
and the energy and the momentum
continues is if you take immediate
massive what my friends massive what
write down in your notes massive action
is the cure-all massive
action is the cure-all if you're having
a difficult time with something
your relationship isn't where you want
it to be your finances are not where you
want to be your body's not where you
want to be your business is not where
you want to be
you need to take massive action and if
that doesn't work try something else if
that doesn't work try something else
keep going with massive action and you
will find the way
because it will give you momentum
fulfillment is an art
what's going to fulfill you is different
than the other person next you're not
going to learn that from anybody else
and you got to find it because success
without fulfillment is the ultimate
failure
and i get those phone calls all the time
for the multi-billionaire
entrepreneur or politician or business
person or a person just won their
academy award
and they're depressed and they can't
tell anybody because they got all their
goals but they're not fulfilled
because they really don't have that
sense of meaning in their life
they went for something and they got it
they achieved
and if you doubt this what i'm saying is
relevant to you or us
or anyone just think about about a year
and what a month ago
we lost um what i consider be a national
treasure robin williams
how many of you loved robin williams
look around them keep your hands up look
and most of you didn't know him almost
every where you go in the world people
love robin williams
by the way was he great at achievement
oh my god that guy
he said he want to make become a great
comedian he did that i want to make the
world laugh he did i want to
make my own tv show he did i wanted the
number one tv show he did it
i want to make movies he did i want an
academy award for not being funny
not his skill set drama and he did it i
want a beautiful family he did it and
then he hung himself
make everybody happy about yourself not
a good plan
so if i had a gift to give you it would
be maybe make a different decision and a
decision is
that no matter what happens in your life
you're going to live in a beautiful
state
a beautiful state and that could be
happy that could be grateful
that could be being generous those are
all beautiful states aren't they it
could be curious
it could be fun it could be playful
you're not limited to one state
but it's different than suffering and
most people
suffering and all suffering i've ever
seen i've traveled 100 countries i've
dealt with
presence of countries and you know
presidents of
businesses ceos i've dealt with people
in prison i've dealt with you name
average people suffering always comes
because you're obsessed about something
related to you
you can only be depressed if you're
focusing on yourself he said no i'm
depressed because it's my kids and
they're not doing well no you're
depressed because you feel you've failed
your kids it's about you it's about how
you think you what you should have done
or shouldn't have done or what someone
did to you or didn't do to you
in the past or the future which don't
even exist so i have a simple goal my
goal is
help people make a decision that says i
don't know what's going to happen
you might get a divorce even though you
don't think so
you might find a family of your family
with cancer
you might have your house get burned
down or have a tornado go by and if you
live in the same place it happens every
two years and you move back we should
talk but
some people seem to do that for some
reason you can't control those things i
can't control those things i don't want
those to happen to you or anybody i love
or anybody who's even a stranger to me
but they're going to happen true
not positive thinking just the truth so
if that's going to happen i say make a
decision now that says
i'm going to live in a beautiful state
and i'm going to find beauty in whatever
life brings me
because life is too short not to what do
you think was the first real
breakthrough that you had
as a teen that started you on your path
and how did you get there
gosh there's so many one of the first
ones i think was probably
um just anchoring in when
my mom and my dad i had four different
fathers my mom was a powerful woman
so she kicked my fourth father out whose
name i carry
and he adopted me and when he went out
she decided it wasn't his side so she
kicked me out too by chasing me out with
a knife and i wasn't
worried she's going to stab me or
anything but i decided this is freedom
and i've got to find a way to make my
life work but i had no money at a 1960
volkswagen i worked
40 dollars a week as a janitor to buy
and pay for and so i had no car i had no
money i know anything
i went and slept in a person's uh
laundry room and then i decided i've got
to figure out what to do and i needed to
feed my mind because i was so depressed
i was so overwhelmed i'm missing my
brother and sister and
feeling just completely out of sorts so
i i got on a bus and i traveled 14 miles
remember because i ended up running it
one time
uh and i went to this bookstore and i
bought this book called the magic of
believing by claudette bristol
the first real book other than maybe
think and grow rich or emerson's essays
and i started on this journey of saying
every single day i'm going to feed my
mind
i'm not going to hope good thoughts show
up i'm going to read biographies
i'm i'm gonna find out what makes people
tick i'm gonna understand what makes me
tick
and i i wanted to read a book a day but
i didn't do that i took a speed reading
class and i read 700 books over seven
years
and they're all personal development
human development psychology physiology
and
what i try to do is take anything that i
learned and apply it
and then when i applied it you know i
was 5-1 in my sophomore year in high
school i'm six seven now i tell people
the difference is personal growth
but sincerely i i i became mr solution
because i
wanted to help everybody so i was this
little fat guy
and i couldn't lose weight and i lost
weight all my buddies were like how'd
you do that i said well here's what i
did and they lost weight and then we all
got girls
and that led you as a young kid you know
that led to where you know if you had a
problem i was mr solution especially if
you're a girl i was
more motivated to help you so the
breakthrough was really understanding
the power of compressing decades into
days
if someone has spent decades of their
life and they compress it into a book
and you can read it in an hour or a few
days you have such an advantage because
when you learn by your own experience
it's painful
and it's slow when you learn by other
people's experience everybody knows in
the financial world other people's money
is leverage right well other people's
experience is more powerful than other
people's money
because you can have the money and lose
it but if you get the experience you can
change it all so i think that was the
beginning for me and it set me on a
lifelong path of
hunger the minimum i do is i want to
know more about my clients than anybody
then they know about themselves
uh i know a man that from australia
decided he was a dentist
and he decided he was tired of people
not showing up he was tired of trying to
bill and not getting paid you know
properly from
various insurance he was taught all
these things one day he just decided to
sit down with every one of his patients
one-on-one and he said i'm changing my
practice
i'm going to do a practice where i'm
going to take a lot less clients and let
go
probably half the clients i have right
now i only want to do business with
people who i personally like
who when they come in i want to sit down
have a cup of tea with them
we'll understand what's going on in
their life what their goals are and i
want to make sure that
everything in my psyche is taking care
of them and helping them augment
the way they look the way they feel and
their vitality
and the health of their system and he
sat down and said so to do that
i want you to know i have some simple
things i'm promising i'll give you the
best dental care of your entire life i'm
promising that if you come in your
appointment you will not be delayed in
one maximum of five minutes
ever uh i'm and he laid out all these
things i'll give the best care there's
this the
most attention he goes but this is what
i'm going to require for patients that
work with me
i'll refer them about someone else if
this is uncomfortable he's that i
require
that if they cancel they're gonna have
to pay for it i require they show up on
time because i'm going to respect them
they respond me
i'm going to also require that in the
next six months that if i do the quality
work i promise they'll give me two
referrals for
two other quality people that i'd
probably want to take care of as well
and he said i'm shutting down any other
form of my business
and i'm going to spend more quality time
with you and i want the referrals
because i don't want to spend time
marketing and selling i want to spend
time putting my attention and making
your life better
he quadrupled his income and cut the
time he spent doing dental work by more
than 60 percent
right just because he became an owner
who owned his business instead of
running around trying to please
everybody and
being frustrated people are canceling
and so forth most of us just don't own
ourselves enough
we have a blast together we laugh you
know we cry we see the impact
and to me there is no dividing line and
for my kids you know like all the work
we do feeding people
my youngest son jarek when he was five
or maybe six probably five
uh we would go and even in the early
days i was feeding families and i'd take
all my friends and we'd build these
baskets up make them great we fed all
the families we had some food left some
baskets left so we went to this place in
oceanside this park
and there's a man lying on the ground in
the toilet area covered with a bunch of
pieces of rags
and so you know i gave it to my son and
i said come on he could barely hold the
thing with so big
i said you know what can i help you give
this to this man he goes and see set it
down next time man i'll say the man
jumped at me grabbed my son's hand and i
jumped my son jumped
and then he just did this and he put it
down
my son is 31 years old now 32 years old
now
he's just gotten married he was working
on kids
his entire life is about contribution
he's got a heart
this big he works his but he does it in
a way that's so fulfilling and his wife
travels with them and they have this
great life and he doesn't have to pick
between work
and mission and he's not burned out and
he's probably been to 100 countries
and i'm proud as hell of them it's like
if you can combine your mission
with your family combine your mission
with some of your friends
then you're going to accomplish a
million times more but if you think it's
a sacrifice
don't do it because then all you're
doing is you're gonna have resentment
later on or frustration later on and
and you really aren't contributing
because it's you're you're trading off
you're not giving
oh great great um yeah dude
uh i i think uh
i'm a nine-year-old kid those who know
me know i'm a nine-year-old child in my
body
pinching myself every day that i get to
do
that i get to do it is extraordinary i
could not would not want to be doing
anything else i mean there's hard work
and it's
and it's like i'm push myself by anybody
else but i love it i love it i love it i
cannot imagine doing anything else
and that's the challenge right the
question is a lot of people are doing
something to get to something else and
that's just wrong i agree and it's a
matter of
don't do cause your parents told you
because you're hurt on an infomercial
because whatever if
do what is your highest calling in life
and love it and so uh i don't work at
all i really don't work
and that's work you know dan has told me
to get rid of it and so i
get rid of it yeah well you know i mean
this
this room is filled with some very high
achievers and
obviously what i wanted to derive from
you guys
is just some insights some how-tos and
what it is you do to just give them
you know perspective and stuff and i
carefully chose some questions
and this one is you're both masters at
achieving what most people consider
impossible and i mean really like what
you guys do most people consider
absolutely impossible so when something
is considered
quote unquote impossible how do you
reframe it so it becomes possible in
your mind
and how much of that is mindset
well i think impossible is not a fact
it's an opinion
when someone tells me it's impossible i
always just look at them anybody around
me knows that they can't do that
that's part of it but if they didn't
know me it's your opinion and they'll
say no science shows and i see and how
many times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible
things are impossible until somebody
does it and so uh
i find that you know most of your
business people you look at businesses
and what does it take to make a business
grow it's not impossible like a business
grow business been shrinking for a long
time or
it's been stuck the real problem is
always the chokehold
is always the psychology and the skills
of the leader
always and 80 of that is psychology and
20
is the mechanics like if you don't know
how to read your financials and you're
trying to fly the plane of your
your company i mean come on you know if
all you do is go down you look at profit
loss and
you see what it is and you have a beer
either way you either celebrate or get
depressed you know something
you know you're going to be in trouble
right but if you have the skill sets
that's one thing but you can get any
skill set if you have the psychology
and any time a business is not growing
it is not because it's impossible
it's because they aren't innovating and
they're not innovating because
they're believing it's impossible i mean
if we all know what does it take to
transform and obviously help people it
takes three things to create a
breakthrough in anything in your
personal life
and your business anywhere you need a
strategy but
that's not the first place you should
look and it's the first place all of us
look
me too it's our inherent thing you want
to lose weight well how do i do it
i want to grow my business how do i do
it it's it's instinctive we've been
trained to think that way but the
problem is the how-to is usually not
that complex
i mean come on 70 of america is what 75
of america now is overweight
is that because it's so complex how to
be fit and strong
right you know only the one percent know
the answers they hide it from you you
have to work your
off to not hear what it takes right
and so so you know i remember i went to
this uh
i went to a ted med center and i watched
about 12 doctors one after another get
up and do these stories about how we
could just get patients
to take their medications and try to
figure out the whole thing and i was
just
looking and going you're all talking
about strategy and you've forgotten
psychology
because strategy is wonderful i'm a
strategist i spend my whole life
figuring out strategies
we both know a strategy could save you a
decade right and business strategy could
save you
you know you could make the difference
between success and failure but
most people have strategies available or
they could get them or you could create
them but the problem is you got a story
and your story is why it isn't working
and the story is
i've tried what what
everything if you tried everything you'd
be fit right
you tried everything you'd be profitable
if you tried everything you'd be there
but people say it you know i'm big bone
that's what i used to say
i'm still big bone but i'm 38 pounds
lighter than i was 25 years ago and i've
never gained it back right
when i was big boned that was my story
all the good ones are gone that's why
i'm not in a relationship
or they're gay and i'm not or again they
are whatever the story is
there's always a story and what i tell
people you know if you can just divorce
the story of your limitation and marry
the truth of your unlimited capacity
then the whole game changes
when you went off on your own you know
that's kind of the point i think people
you know most businesses fail at the
beginning in the first few years so
there you are on your own
what do you think were the keys to
success those first few years by
yourself
obsession with adding more value than
anybody else ever dreamed of i mean my
entire
life from the very beginning days was
how do i do more for others than
anyone else on earth how do i give them
experiences that are lasting how do i
create change where change was
impossible
how do i take somebody's been in therapy
for seven years in an hour produce that
result
and the way i did that was by
challenging traditional psychologists
and psychiatrists and getting on
national radio
and saying give me your worst patient
i'll handle in an hour which was pretty
abrasive
you know as a young kid you can get by
with that stuff but the best part was
i backed it up and so one of the first
interventions i did was in vancouver
british columbia canada i got on the
radio
and this psychiatrist got on the phone
and just on the radio live and just
thrashed me you're a liar you're a
charlatan people like you should not be
allowed on the radio
and i said sir i said uh i said are you
you know a scientist he said of course
i'm a physician
i said well a scientist would never make
an assumption
and i said you've never met me right now
you've never met my clients now and
you're calling me a liar on national
radio
i said she must be stating your
hypothesis your hypothesis
is that i'm a liar in a charlatan if
you're studying hypothesis and you're
truly a scientist you've got to be
willing to test it
am i right yep he goes well yeah it's
great i'm doing a free guest event
at the holiday inn tomorrow night anyone
hearing my voice can come
i'm going to do a series of
demonstrations and i'm going to take one
of your clients and check around i said
share with me
somebody that you've never been able to
change i said i'm sure you got plenty of
those
you want to play hardball like play
hardcore because we all have patience
that aren't made of change yet i said i
haven't found any
because i've done three therapies total
but i had so much belief
it's a long story short he told me this
woman you've been working on for seven
years
with a snake phobia a phobia is not just
a fear it's an uncontrolled response to
fear so like
she dreamed the snake would bite around
the face and then the adrenaline would
shoot through her body and wake her up
and does it happen four to seven times a
night seven years
so you know he was put in a corner and
said he brought her down and it took me
about 15 minutes at the end of it
i tested first and she screamed and
shaking and then i wrapped the snake
around her
and that changed my entire career
because in that moment
every there was no question everybody
saw that this woman is transformed i
said you've been treated by that
psychiatrist for how many years
seven years then i took on sports stars
and then i
turned around you know i did some work
with mother teresa nelson mandela and
bill clinton
and as the years went by it just built
and built it though everyone in this
room knows how to create
you're not a manager of your life you're
a creator of your life or you wouldn't
be in this room
how do you create your life you get
hungry for something don't you
who has done something in your life that
once seemed difficult or impossible
and now it's part of your life who's got
something in your life in this area say
i
how did you do it you created it three
ways number one
you decided there's something you wanted
so bad that you unleashed all your
desire
you became obsessed with it if it was a
business or a car or a relationship
or a transformation in your body if
there's something you once envisioned
and now it's real
it's because you didn't just envision it
you brought so much emotion to it
that now it's in your life it was once a
dream
it was once a goal and now it's in your
life how many have something like that
in your life now say i you may
take it for granted now hopefully not
but it was once just a vision it may
have seemed impossible at one time
so how did you do it you started with a
concrete vision of what you wanted
and you focused on it continuously
didn't you
wherever focus goes energy
flows you envisioned something you got
clear about it and then you started
thinking about all the reasons why you
wanted it
you got excited about it said this is
what's next for me now
i want this you may have dreamed about
it thought about it talked about it
but when you focus on something
continuously something magical happens
you get insights don't you you overhear
a conversation you hear something you
wouldn't have heard if you didn't have
that outcome or goal that you wanted so
badly
who's ever come up with something
obsessed about it didn't even know how
to do it
and it just happened and it came
together who's had that experience say i
so why don't we tap into that power now
for your business in life
the goal if you own a business and i
would assume a lot of your viewers are
business owners are getting started in
business
no matter how good you are in business
think about this the one universal rule
that
in finance know is diversification it's
the only free lunch you've got to
diversify
because if you put all your eggs in one
basket no matter how good the basket is
one day that real estate market that
stock market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in
radel you showed me statistically it'll
drop 50 to
70 percent on a day now if you're later
in life when that happens it's over for
you
right so you have to diversify and yet
most people they know real estate so
they do it or they know stocks they do
it or they grew up with their hand
their parents flipping things and it's
the wrong thing to do
so you've got to diversify in order for
you to be able to truly succeed
and that's why when you own a business
yeah
if you put all your money in your
business which is what most of us do
naturally
you've seen a lot of risk yeah you put
all your eggs in one basket
and there's things that can happen i
mean you know you're let's say you spent
20 years
and you figured out how to put together
the ultimate map
you know and you remember garmin came
out with this thing called the tomtom i
don't know if you remember you used to
put on your
are you old enough to remember that you
could try on your phone yeah or you just
put on your
dash cost a hundred bucks it was a
breakthrough
they were making like 100 million or
something or yeah yeah six months later
what happened
the iphone came out with google maps
was my friend came out with it put
google maps put their own map on here
and
asked how much zero what's it gonna do
your business when someone takes your
product reserve and gives away for free
so i always tell people competition
happens
technology happens what you must do is
have a second business
with no with no moving parts no people
no time maybe it takes you
two to three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two three times a year that's it yeah go
on with your life
now if there's a trouble in your
business you're financially set i in my
life
at 31 companies now we have you know
what we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we do five
billion in sales
i mean i that used to be you know me and
my seminar business it's grown
geometrically
but with all those moving parts the only
way i've been able to succeed is because
i've taken every one of those businesses
and i've diversified my assets so that
when things were in trouble
i still have enough economics to take
care of myself and keep the business
going so
everybody needs to create a money
machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about what
are the trade-offs that you would
consider like you know
we work ours off we do a lot of stuff
but this is what we had to sacrifice in
order to do it
if you think of that way i think if you
think of it as a sacrifice um
then you're going to build frustration
or resentment i i really don't
if you think of the sacrifice you
shouldn't do it i think the challenge is
that most people have this illusion
about
life work balance and i think that's
that's
you know if you're going to accomplish
it and it's what people are laughing
because you know
right what's true is life work
integration so i was just in 21 country
or
721 days but who's with me is my family
who's with me as my friends and i've
done well enough to have a plane and
bedrooms and all that kind of cool stuff
makes it but when i didn't we still
we huffed it together and beginning days
it was coach and dragging ourselves
around but
i thought it was great for my kids to
have schooling but i thought an
education was more valuable and
traveling the earth was a part of that
um but you know we're in the middle of
this crazy schedule but
it's not work it's a mission when it's
work it's that i always ask people i
said
how would you describe what you do and
people are saying is it work is it
career or is it mission
and most people of course say it's work
and that's exactly what it is it's heavy
if it's you know if it's your career
it gives you something more but your
mission it doesn't wear you out
it brings energy to you it's fulfilling
and if you can tie your mission in with
the people that you love
it's pretty cool you know there's some
people that assume they're my friends i
see dean here in the front row here and
it's like we're all on this mission and
we find time to connect and be with each
other and have a blast with each other
but we're sharing about things
that matter i'm not a person to go to a
party and like you know go in the corner
and chit chat it's like you want to talk
about something deep let's rock you down
let me let me go home and be with my
family you know let me go
do something fun some of that nature if
you can combine your mission
with your family combine your mission
with some of your friends
then you're going to accomplish a
million times more but if you think it's
a sacrifice
don't do it because then all you're
doing is you're going to have resentment
later on or frustration later on and
and you really aren't contributing
because it's you're you're trading off
you're not giving
most people have a belief about what
their real potential is no matter what
you tell them
and that affects how much action they
take and of course that affects the
result and then ironically
that result reinforces their belief
and then that belief affects it so i'll
give an example let's say a person
has unlimited potential we all agree but
they take little action little results
why
because they have to start with a
problem with their belief they don't
believe
it's really going to happen for me maybe
for frank kearns because it got the cool
hair and stuff or maybe it's for you
because
you're so driven but it's not me maybe
tony robbins because he's a freak got
these big teeth whatever their thought
process is right they got this thing
right
but what happens is if you believe that
there's very little potential
how much action you're going to take
nothing nothing little and when you take
little potential with a little action
what kind of results you get
lousy little results and when you get
little results what does that do to your
belief
you go see i told you this was a waste
of time told you this wouldn't work
and then what happens you tap even less
potential you take even less action you
get even worse results and your belief
gets even weaker
and this feeds on itself until you are
in a downward spiral
poisonous it's poisonous and it's
self-fulfilling now what if something
could happen that could come along
and fill you with a sense of absolute
certainty not like i believe but mean
where you know
in you guys case mine as well we knew
because we
had to because we burned the boats there
was no other option we had to find the
way
we had we weren't going to live that way
we all did it in different ways and for
different reasons but in essence that
was it
if you get yourself in a state of
certainty that this is going to work
i'm gonna find the way and if this
doesn't work i will make the way then
you tap
a lot more potential and when you're
certain in your potential you take
massive action when you take massive
action you really believe in something
you get
great results when you get great results
your brain goes see i told you i was a
stud
i told you this thing would work out now
you're even stronger you tap more
potential take greater action better
results that's how you went from 300
bucks in a week
to 2505 days to 100 000 in a month
to a million bucks in a day same thing
with you and we get momentum why the
rich get richer the poor get poorer
now some people go out and they go well
i'm going to take a bunch of action all
right
i'm going to open this product i'm going
to try it and they'll say to you i even
did it
but it's like a salesman who goes and
knocks on the door and he knocks on 100
doors and says
you don't want one of these yeah exactly
right yeah and even if he doesn't say it
verbally his face says it because
he doesn't believe it's going to work so
his voice his body the execution is so
weak maybe if he talks to a hundred
people somebody's gonna buy out of pity
he's gonna want his kids to starve right
but he's not gonna get the result
so the core difference in people is how
do you produce certainty
when the world isn't giving it to you
you go out you try and you're trying
your case you're a hundred thousand of
debt and nothing's working
how do you keep yourself going the way
you did it the way i did it the way
you're doing it we may not have done it
consciously
is we didn't change our potential that
was there
and it wasn't even taking more action
taking more action with beliefs not
gonna work it's not gonna change
anything
we got results in our head that made us
feel certain as if it had already
happened
put your hands on your heart if you
would okay my hands on my heart feel
your heart close your eyes and really
breathe in your heart those at home
could do the same so they can test this
out
and those at home think of something
that's really bothered your ideal it is
seven or above and you really want to
resolve it and you have it
could be a relationship situation a
business situation kids whatever
breathe in your heart and actually
physically feel your heart
feel it filling with blood and oxygen
feel the beauty of your heart ah yes
i love getting a heart exam because you
get to hear that
the strength of your heart yeah feel the
beauty the strength
and through what you're grateful your
heart has guided you to do in this life
so many beautiful things
especially you mm-hmm and as you're
breathing and feeling that i want you to
think of
three things one at a time just for a
couple minutes we'll do a short version
here i know you don't have a couple
minutes
but of things you're really grateful for
but something that could be little or
big
but if you step into that moment you can
feel it right now like you're there
yeah yeah breathe it feel it
enjoy it fill up with it and then think
of a second one
that you can feel really grateful for
and see it through your own eyes as if
you were there
and really take it in okay and then
think of a third one
finally really you'd really enjoy i feel
like it was a blessing
such a beautiful blessing in your life
sometimes coincidences are great because
we know we didn't create them
we were guided right yeah yeah yeah so
as you continue that with your eyes
closed
breathing there yeah then ask yourself
about that situation but stay breathing
your heart stand that same feeling
so you're in a beautiful state and just
ask yourself
in that situation all i need to remember
is
all i need to focus on is all i need to
do is what
in that situation those bother me
breathing in my heart feeling the same
beauty
all i need to remember is all i need to
focus on is all i need to believe all i
need to do is
what and your heart knows the answer
can you feel it do you know the answer
is appreciate that i'm even in this
position
to even have that as a dilemma yeah yeah
and how does that feel now when you
think about it it feels like done
instead of complaining you got to say
where are the skill sets valued in the
marketplace and how do i work harder on
myself
than anything else because if i become
more valuable
then i will be able to give more do more
and change more when i interviewed
warren buffett i asked the most
important investment he ever made in his
life you know what he said it was i was
thinking all the companies they've done
you know
he said tony going to dale carnegie said
what
he goes because by developing myself
that's the most
important investment those skill sets
learning how to persuade learning how to
speak learning an influence all my ideas
would have died on my lips
if i hadn't be able to influence and i
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing i ever did in my life you
said
i physically stress my body to extremes
because
i've developed a process to take people
and help them change in
a weekend but my idea of the weekend is
50 hours and most people won't sit for a
three-hour movie
so uh you know that somebody spent 300
million dollars on and i got 12 000
people in a stadium i got back from last
night up in san jose we had four days
and nights like this and uh we actually
had a halter on me and
a group of researchers that worked with
olympic athletes and
i burned 9 500 calories in one day in
nine hours the battery died before i
finished i
i went 12 hours um i did uh
i burned enough calories for two
marathons my jumps because i'm jumping
constantly was the equivalent of two nba
games uh my lactate as you all know at
one is
hard to talk it was 14 and i was still
going strong at 12 hours
so there's some physical stress because
i'm a believer that talking is
you got to go deep you got to get people
to experience things i think a belief is
a poor substitute for an experience
and if i get someone experience changing
something if i can do it in a really
potent way where they really
feel it then you know if you do that
over and again you start to get someone
actually be trained to get a new result
it's not about belief uh you know belief
is important it's not about confidence i
heard that kind of description it's
never bullets but it's strategy
but if you don't have the certainty
you're not going to execute so i think
i've spent a lifetime accumulating
patterns there are patterns we all have
they're patterns that make you angry
patterns that make you sad patterns make
you excited patterns that make you
grateful
um patterns in health as you well know
so like all of you who are the best at
what you do
i'm massively into pattern recognition
pattern utilization and pattern creation
and those things help me to create
changes that wouldn't have happened
before
when people talk about work work-life
balance i was talking to mary calhoun
erdos who's
um you know morgan says you know she
manages 2.6
trillion for the t dollars probably the
most influential woman in the financial
world brilliant woman
and i asked her because you know i was
interviewing 50 of the smartest
financial people on the face of the
earth
i said i know you're very deeply caring
my mom
and your wife and how do you balance all
that and she said tony
she goes i read this one of your books
she goes there is no such thing as
work-life balance there's only work-life
integration
and i really believe that in my soul so
in my companies
uh you know my wife and i we live our
mission together we're 24 7 365 together
and we love it
um because we're driven by the same
things um one of my sons is a partner in
several of my financial businesses
my other sons is in the coaching
business um you know my daughter's an
actress
and you know totally different business
but she cares for people the same way so
there's a common denominator within our
family we're all so mission driven
that we don't have to separate the two
when your
family is involved involved in your
mission you're not pulled apart
you're pulled together in the same
direction i think the hard part is so
many families
have totally different lives they come
together when they're exhausted
and try to have a relationship together
and i think that's really hard for
people today
i always encourage people to say listen
in in your partnership in life
you want to find somebody who's your
best friend because intimacy and passion
is easy to turn on
but friendship is not and if you have a
friend who shares your values and your
mission and
if you're privileged enough to do things
together as a business owner i find that
to be
the greatest possibility of that work
life integration i always tell people
the most valuable lesson i got from my
mentor jim rohn
was i asked my father worked two jobs we
were always broke
we had no money for food and we lived in
a community we moved to which was i
thought they were all rich and we were
on the other side of the tracks it was
lower middle class but compared to where
we lived before these people seem rich
compared to us
and i just didn't understand it and jim
said to me tony
it's not about the value of your soul
it's about the value of you in the
marketplace
and your father's skills are not that
valuable he used to take he was an
underground parking attendant and he
would take people's ticket
and make change well the research now
shows is being done at yale is being
done overseas in england as well
and they found that 40 percent of all
jobs they project in the next 10 years
are going to disappear because of
technology
it's going to be replaced by an
algorithm it's going to change you know
all these guys on wall street you're
seeing all these algorithms take over
and they're getting rid of all these
traders
right it's changing radically these and
these hedge funds there's three million
truck drivers
self-driving cars are here in the next
five years they will be the standard
certainly within seven or eight years
are you gonna hire someone who can only
work eight hours a day
and sometimes gets drunk or can make a
mistake when you can
buy a machine right down the machine and
be in a position where it works 24 hours
a day driving
but no one is telling these drivers this
and it's they have to retool
now so technology is the biggest
challenge
labor is less valuable because of
efficiencies with technology and it's
going to get
better and better for technology which
is scary when you think about what's
going to happen for jobs
so i say to people you got to
participate in your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
that bernie sanders has of providing
free education sounds wonderful but the
education he wants to do is community
college
there are no skill sets in community
colleges today for the most part
that are going to prepare you for the
economy or a job that's there so what is
that going to do you're just going to
waste more money more time
we need to retool ourselves the
government's not going to do it for you
these thoughts that we have we think
there are thoughts so it makes it really
hard to change them
and people meditate try to not think
possible show me some of your thumbnails
successfully
consistently everybody the mind
thinks thoughts but here's the
distinction
if i told you 100 years ago we were
going to fly to the moon and back you
would have called me a lunatic that's
where the charm comes from
people still use it and it doesn't make
any sense because the lunatic is
somebody thought we go to the moon back
we've done it right
i didn't know that yeah but if
i would have told you 100 years ago that
there's going to be a box in your pocket
and you're going to pull this thing out
you're going to hit a couple buttons and
then
it's going to capture invisible waves
that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're going
to see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're going to talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves
and when you use your body in a certain
way if i sit like this
i'm going to channel i'm going to tap
into a different channel those waves
that if i'm sitting like this
kind of like a tv set if i turn one
channel might be a comedy channel i'm
going to see a lot of laughter turn
another one it's horror channel
turn another channel it's a romance
channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize
that your thoughts do you think are your
thoughts there's nothing unique about
your thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years
you're just tapping into them because of
what you're doing with your body that
makes you either fearful or passionate
or courageous or whatever
you're feeling as you go in those states
you get different thoughts
so what i want people to see is they
learn how to just see those thoughts go
by
learn how to be entertained by those
thoughts because i have crazy thoughts
and
but what i've gotten good at is going
look at that crazy thought that's not me
that's of the mind
not your mind because if it's you how do
you change you pretty hard
but i really truly know there's i
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's
original you call them your thoughts but
they're not you've stolen them
name it around forever when you see that
it's easier to let go of them
and letting go of those thoughts is one
of the ways that you free yourself and
then again the more you do it just like
a muscle
you get better and better and better and
all of a sudden the [ __ ] that used to
make you crazy or stressed out and like
how many things have you worried about
that never came to be and some people
their life is good so they worry about
other people
you know so they're never not worried
right so it's really just a pattern if
you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion
it's like what are we really after money
you don't have money you want pieces of
paper with the
pictures the deceased notables on it you
want we think money will give you you
think it'll give you freedom or security
or stability
or love it won't give you love it'll get
you sex it won't get you your love money
won't right
so really what you're after is the
emotion and so what i want people to get
is the emotion they want now and all it
is is a new habit
it's learning to discipline this mind
right
by realizing the mind thoughts are out
there
and letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can i love about
this what can i appreciate it's like
if you can learn to love or at least
appreciate
start to enjoy the things that you used
to get upset about
how much freedom would you have how much
more joy you have and i know people got
billions of dollars i've coached them
who was like holy they live in scarcity
all the time one man
i'll never forget he's screaming at his
wife i'm in the media i mean
i'm in the house and he's screaming at
his wife because she spent some money on
a bunch of outfits and stuff like that
he's a multi-billionaire he couldn't
spend all his money in his lifetime and
then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and i'm
like i pulled him outside afterwards and
i said
what do you do this for and what are you
doing for it and he's like well it's
just it's the principle thing i said no
the principle thing is do you love these
people
and do you want them to have an abundant
life when you have there's
you don't have one loss but you live
like you're poor
you know and it's like i finally got
through to him but so many people
that's why i say money doesn't change
you money magnifies who you are
so you want to expand the depth of who
you are and free yourself from suffering
by just knowing it's a pattern of
thought and you can change the pattern
of thought
it's like you know you get on an
airplane what's the first thing they say
if we get into trouble
mask will come down oxygen's there and
the first thing you got to do is put it
on your kid
right no why who do they tell you to put
it on yourself you selfish bastard
what's the deal here right
but it's because we don't take care of
ourselves we can't tear them so for
leaders what i always tell them is it's
you first it starts with you
and it starts with your psychology
eighty percent of growing a business if
you look at what the chokehold is on a
business
it's always the leader and eighty
percent of that chokehold is the
psychology
20's the mechanics i mean people in this
room know the mechanics and strategies
beyond what anybody on earth knows in
their category
so it's really about you being in the
state where you execute it's like i
always tell people knowledge is not
power it's total technologist potential
power
execution trump's knowledge every day of
the week and so my life is
how do you get yourself to execute and
execution comes from learning to put
yourself in that right state
i really believe in order to influence
people you got to know what already
influences them
the mistake that we make is we don't
connect enough to figure out who this
person is
and what most of us do is try to lead
other people by influencing them
the way we'd be influenced they try to
influence their kid to clean the room
the way that would make you do it
but even though they're your kid they're
different than you and so they're going
to do it for a different set of reasons
than what you would do it for you might
have done it because someone told you to
but your kids can
come all day long that's not it there
has to be something else
it's a sense of freedom to get from it
or a sense of mass just something that's
going to move them
so i always say there are two things
that influence everyone
if you want to be a leader you have to
know how to change other people's states
a person is in a no state a person's in
an angry state a person's in a
frustrated state you have to be able to
influence their state because if you
change their state
you're going to change the result they
get but the second thing you have to
understand is what are people's
blueprints
blueprints my shorthand for what are the
values
what do they believe what do they fear i
always say to people that life is found
in the dance between what you desire
most and what you fear most
if i want to lead you and support you i
got to know your goals your desires i
don't know what you're scared about what
you're fearful about what stresses you
out
and if i understand that i can
communicate in a way that'll inspire you
to maximize
not only when i'm here that's management
leadership is i'm
gone and you've raised your own standard
and you're going to continue to perform
at a higher level
how to do something is the wrong
sequence to start with like
what's the strategy for being fit and
healthy it's not that complex and yet
70 of the u.s is overweight it's like
you just have to do it
it's not a strategy problem what it is
is why aren't they doing it
it's because they have a story and
everyone does this
entrepreneurs business people everyone
does this
when we get fearful when we've tried
something and we're not succeeding as
fast as we want when we
are afraid of failing we come up with a
story about
how it's not our fault or how we're
going to do it in the future because
then we don't have to feel bad
feeling bad makes us have to deal with
it most people are overwhelmed so they
just
they come up with a story about i've
tried everything if you tried everything
you'd be fit
you know i tried millions of things
millions name them three things they did
50 times that don't work but i think if
you can come up when you change the
story when you come up with a new set of
beliefs
you'll find yourself finding the
strategy or using the strategies that
already work that are there that right
now your mind says oh it won't work
and the best way to change people you
got strategy story is state
and i always share this with business
owners you've got to be able to produce
a different state in your people there
has to be something compelling there has
to be a sense of mission
what's your how do you get better how do
you know
listen i was good today but i want to be
great what are the metrics you use i
mean is there data you get back
how do you improve well we have all the
social media data which we
we use big data to take a look at but i
also look at it individually because
there's nuances that you pick up in that
way so i feed that look at that
but my biggest piece is watching the
audience and then you know every day in
my life i get feedback i'm walking down
the street a dozen people come and tell
me these beautiful stories now the life
has changed
and very much like like she shared
earlier they'll give me way too much
credit so i always straighten them out
and go look you did this i'm glad i got
to help
um and i try to keep that balance with
everybody but my measurement is
both emotional state impact as well as
execution did they lose 20 pounds did
they go turn their business around
you know my business is organized around
i really want to help people improve
all the quality areas of their life but
there's about seven that matter the most
it's your body it's your emotions it's
your relationships it's the way you
manage time
it's finances it's your work and it's
the spiritual side of life
and so what i spent my life doing is
modeling people that are the best of the
world you find a couple have been
together for
65 years in their 80s uh late 80s and
they're still making love and passionate
not just hanging out
they're not lucky they're doing
something different so i'm constantly
finding those patterns so that hopefully
i can compress decades into days i can
learn from those decades of life
experience
say that bring the answer here to myself
and others and see a measurable impact
when you're in a negative state you
don't perform at a higher level when
you're in a negative state
it affects your biochemistry affects
your immune system you're in a negative
state affects the people around you when
you're in a great state
perform better enjoy life more greater
impact all the above so
it's intelligent to be at a peak state
but you know
you only can manage what you measure
like a business
you know if i want to when i take
company over and turn around and start
measuring things and i measure the most
important things and the more you
measure the better you'll get because
you get more instead of measuring once a
year if you're measuring you know once a
week
you have 52 times to improve it versus
one
so i started measuring and i said i'm
gonna live in a beautiful state no
matter what every day
now in order to do that i have to do two
things a i have to acknowledge that i've
been suffering and i need to figure out
what my favorite flavor of suffering is
and i played off of that with myself and
i thought frustrated and pissed off were
pretty useful for me
in fact i realized that my happiness was
so cheap because all i needed was this
thing and i could lose my happiness
because
ding something cool or ding something
not so cool when you got 1200 employees
what are the chances right now that one
of them is doing something to screw up
not consciously they're just not doing
what they're supposed to do
basically 100 chance and if i was near
this i'd get triggered and i go
and my happiness would disappear so what
i began to say is
i want to be happy even if they screw up
i want to be happy and they
they lost a million bucks i want to be
happy like if my happiness is dependent
upon other people behaving a certain way
the way i want them to i'm pretty
influential guy but i'm not
god right and everybody's got their own
things that they're doing
i'm never going to stay happy and if i
have to even make my happiness based on
me behaving a perfect way every moment
that's not going to happen
so i gave room for life
and i decided to make a real decision
that's my invitation to people here and
then i'll answer your question i know
first you got to make the decision that
says life is too short to suffer
i mean i don't know what's going to
happen
in your lifetime with your children with
your wife with your economics your
business i'm sure you're going to do
well everything but there's things
outside our control the government could
change the rules on something right
the rules have changed before around
direct marketing and so forth
um your somebody your family could get
very ill someone can die in our families
right you almost talk about it but can
happen
if your happiness is only going to be
when everything matches how you think it
should be
you're not going to be there and my view
is that
there's power and happiness we we
downplay at this culture
that when a person is happy they attract
other people when a person is happy they
live longer that's a fact when people
are happier they earn more
right they do better in their careers i
mean these are physiological these are
measured facts in our society and yet we
poo poo happiness in our world like oh
it's
being enthusiastic or something like
that no it's being inspired in spirit
feeling
alive so what i did was is as much
energy or passion i had before i still
had that but what i found was what was
the stuff that would suck
away that energy and so now to answer
your question how would i know
number one i put the line in the sand
and said these are the ones i tend to
drop into
i'm not doing any more and if i find it
i need a rule i got 90 seconds to get
out
all right 90 second rule that should
have been the four-hour rule
on certain things 90 seconds was easy
but you know certainly you should get
hooked
totally and i was like maybe the day
rule and some of them initially
but as i did it more and more it's like
a muscle
and when you use a muscle over and over
again it works it's there for you
and so how i know dance questions along
with the expression but without that i
don't think people understand what we're
talking about
is i sense tension in my body like
when you're in a beautiful state things
flow when there's a tension
you can feel it in your face you have
somebody says somebody somebody has them
somebody didn't do something
somebody use a certain term somebody you
dropped something out or you did
something or you should have done
whenever that happens there's a tension
and so i've really
trained myself to feel that tension and
when i feel i go
90 seconds and it's a game now 90
seconds
and since i value that happiness so much
not like a deluded person i'm so happy
like i value being in a beautiful state
because it may not be happy it may be
driven it may be courageous it may be
feeling bold
it may be love it may be compassion
for someone else or even myself right
and i've always have come back with
other people and
myself right and so what i began to do
is realize holy cow this is something
that
could change everything and so that 90
second rule i feel the tension
and then here's what i do i know that
it's triggered by one of three
language patterns as a trigger as an
example lost less than ever
if you perceive that something
someone you're counting on they failed
to do something or they failed to say
something say something or um or you
failed to do something
or say something you should have then
what happens is that tension starts to
show up because your brain goes
i lost that opportunity i lost this
moment i lost that respect i lost this
love
i lost the money i lost whatever you
thought you lost and loss is always an
illusion
it was like the next opportunity is two
minutes around the corner you know
it's it's not that complex if we look
for it if we find it if we don't live in
the illusion of loss
or less is the next one if you think
because he or she did something or
didn't do it
you have less of something you value
less love less joy less excitement less
time less energy less economics
less respect you're going to suffer
inside you know some people suffer by
being
angry some people suffer by feeling sad
everyone has different flavors right
right you're going to suffer
and the worst one is never if you think
because she or he did this or
donald trump did something or didn't do
it or mary sue or you
south didn't do it and now you'll never
have that love
you'll never have that respect you'll
never have that joy you'll never have
that economics once you believe that
stuff
then the suffering stays so the way out
of loss
less never is always appreciation
or gratitude or love if you look at a
business
the choke hold on the growth of any
business is always
the psychology and the skill set of the
leader and it's 80
psychology and 20 mechanics meaning so
many small businesses you know
um the the owner might be an incredible
innovator
maybe they write incredible code maybe
they're a tremendous influencer
but they don't know the economic side of
their business right and they find
themselves getting in trouble because
somebody's giving them financial
information after the fact they don't
have true financial intelligence to make
decisions
and they get caught up can you can you
give me an example of a business like
that you have to name names no no
i'll pick my own examples i had several
companies early in my career that were
near bankruptcy because i would sit down
and i would i knew how to produce
products it would change people's lives
i knew how to market i knew how to build
teams of people but what i didn't know
was finance so i'd look and say you know
okay
how are we doing oh you got a great you
know you got a 20 profit
you know you got two million dollars in
profit those days little tiny company
and i come to the end of the year there
was no cash right i didn't know that
profit is a theory
right you know and so just not having
that skill or someone might be really
great in finance but they're not any
good in marketing
so sometimes it's a skill problem but 80
of it
you can solve those skills you can get
those skills if you can change your
psychology but when you accept that oh
my god the market's down or oh my god
the economy in our is down
when you allow the environment to
control your psychology
you're not gonna win my goal in the book
is really for people to be happy and
more fulfilled
because you can have a ton of money and
still be miserable right you know so
it's it's really it's it's like
mastering the science of achievement but
also the art of fulfillment
it's about if you're totally successful
you're not fulfilled
then what do you have you have nothing
you know you made everybody happy about
yourself
uh you know that's the worst thing
you've got that's robin williams is a
beautiful man
so it's a beautiful man killed himself
right and he achieved everything most
people ever dream i've had a beautiful
family
you've made the whole world laugh
hundreds of million people love him
but he didn't figure out how to end the
suffering money won't do that
most entrepreneurs are artists in their
nature you know i look at three types of
personalities
an artist is somebody that has a
tremendous gift
a skill an ability a talent you know
like an athlete
uh you know curry is in the nba as an
incredible artist
uh some people they're their artist
sales they can sell iceland eskimos some
people it's writing software they're
incredible
we're designing clothes and most
businesses are started by an artist who
says i can do it better
but they don't realize that as you start
to try to grow a business
you're the most talented employee you
have in the beginning and the cheapest
one
right yeah and now you have to hire
other people and you know they're not
going to do as good a job and it ties
people into this
negative effect what i really see is the
biggest mistake that these individuals
make is they don't understand
business they get in because they want
to do good work for their client
and most of them as you know 96 are gone
in ten years and the four percent that
survive
they aren't necessarily profitable i
mean five percent of all businesses ever
crack a million dollars
gross not net profitability gross
and you have point zero zero zero six so
it's six
one hundred six out of a hundred
thousand businesses
will ever do 10 million gross so
i say to people in business i never
encourage people to get a business i
try to push them away because it's too
hard if you don't have the internal
drive to make it through that
psychologically you're better partnering
with somebody you're better doing
something else
i think understanding business is the
challenge and i always say that
80 percent of the chokehold on the
growth of any business
is always the owner it's the leader and
eighty percent of that is their
psychology
and twenty percent of skills like if you
don't have a market you're in trouble
most most entrepreneurs get in trouble
because they don't know how to read
their financials they don't have a clue
i didn't either you know it's like you
can go out on a plane on a day like
today that's a decent day
and you can fly if you're a pilot with
what they call visual flying world so
you can look
out around you and you can fly you get
in a storm
you better be able to read those
instruments or you're to die and most
entrepreneurs know how to read those
instruments they look down and they see
profit loss and they go oh i made a
profit or i made a loss and they have a
beer either way i wanted to drown out
the pain or the other one to celebrate
right
and profit is a theory as you know
accounting
is a very special language and unless
you understand
how to use accounting to make better
decisions until you learn to understand
and measure things in a way that
gives you better decision making
capability
then you get broadsided and you know
profitability you get a lot of profit no
cash
so i think not understanding the full
aspect of the business
not managing your own psychology and not
knowing your numbers would be three
critical things that i think sabotage
most businesses but you can't have a
standard education
and expect to have an extraordinary life
it's not going to happen
the one breakthrough for all leaders is
constant never-ending improvement and
that means
educating yourself and continuing to
develop even greater emotional mastery
because that's what affects whether you
execute or not
the opportunity for self-education is
there we have to change our psychology
from
i'm going to do what everybody else does
and i'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore to
the reality is this the greatest time to
be alive
if you're growing you're learning you're
educating and you're developing valuable
skills
i always tell people i said tell me tell
me your schedule and they'll go well you
know i go to work and i work
nine to five and i come home i'm
exhausted and so you know when am i
going to start a business i said well
what about the other eight hour shift
because that's what i did right i had to
be able to work from eight to five in a
normal job and then i started working as
a janitor because i work my own hours in
the middle of the night
but i worked eight to five and literally
i'd come home i'd get a bite to eat
and then i'd start my work at 6 pm 6 30
p.m and i go from 6
30 to 2 a.m and i'd get another seven
eight hours in and that's how i built
everything in the beginning
that's honestly what's required and to
not do that
is to cheat yourself because in the end
what we get will never make us happy i
don't care how many stars on your chart
how many academy awards how much money
you make what makes us happy is
progress progress equals happiness if
you're not growing
you're dying inside when i was growing
up i went through a really tough
childhood
my mom was a beautiful soul but she
abused prescription drugs and alcohol
and you know people have different
personalities in that area and she would
i'm the oldest i have a younger brother
five younger sisters seven years younger
and
she bashed my head against the wall
she'd think i was lying and she pulled
liquid soap down my throat till i threw
up it was pretty brutal
but it made me become a practical
psychologist
it made me have to learn what makes
people get crazy get angry get excited
get loved and i had to learn how to
manage her to protect my brother and
sister then to some extent myself
um and so you know if my mom had been
the woman i'd hoped she'd been
i wouldn't be the man i'm proud to be so
it all worked out in
a very beautiful way but it made me i
had so much suffering in my life i don't
want any human to suffer
and i'm effing driven to end suffering
wherever i can possibly make a
difference i don't understand suffering
i want them to experience the joy and
the happiness and the freedom and the
love and
the the opportunity to live life on
their terms
but do you have to fail to be successful
you have to have suffering to be
successful
well you have to fail i don't know if
you have suffer you know the old phrase
you know pain is part of life suffering
is a choice right
what should we as business owners and
professional business owners what should
we never give up on
well i think um i think you have to
decide what's most important to you and
what are you doing all this for
if you're just doing it for money it's a
burnout for anything
so you got to just ask yourself what you
want to give up on is why did you get in
the business originally what is it you
really want and economic freedom should
be
clearly one of those things for people
but time freedom should be there also
that's why
i work with dennis when they go through
business mastery to make them an owner
so they can start to say you know i
really could have somebody else in some
of these
taking over some of these clients and
most are scared to do that initially
because that's my
income we show them how to time it so
that gradually you end up getting more
income from other people working than
yourself
then you do your best work you know it's
like the goal is
get financially free not so you never
work again because if you don't ever
work again
you'll dry up inside you know it's like
when i was growing up everybody's like
making the money to get rich and retire
so i did that at 26 which was
so absurd the amount of money i had i
thought was more than you could spend of
course that was not true um
but but what i learned is it's really
about making money you don't ever have
to work again and then you work harder
and you enjoy it more you know steve
wins a different am i built you know
most of las vegas
and you it is what 74 peter goober who's
here now a friend of mine who owns the
warriors los angeles dodgers
uh he owns movie companies you know 74
years old
works does more today than when i knew
when he was 50.
um warren buffett was 84 85 now
works harder today than ever none
because it's so fulfilling but it's
different when you don't have to work
and you work then you have to work and
you work it's like a different
being who plays golf in this room
anybody play golf so
if i said to you let's go play golf and
by the way i'm a terrible golfer i never
play and truthfully i only play like six
eight holes i just got for some fun a
little bit with my wife and friends
and as we're walking along i tell you
that but as we get up to the first hole
i say you know
just to make it a little more
interesting why don't we bet a dime a
hole
just so there's something on the line
now most people are going to go
no problem you're not going to go you
know see a shark is he setting me up
10 cents oh how many holes are there 18
holes how much i got at risk
a buck 80 right okay not a big deal and
then i'm just about to get up there and
hit the first ball and i see you know
just make it a little more interesting
why don't we just double at each hole
so what would that be first hole is 10
cents so the second hole is
20 cents third hole would be 40 cents
fourth hole is going to be 80 cents
fifth hole is going to be
buck 60 six hole is going to be 320. now
stop how many holes are there
18. so we're one-third the way through
and it's three dollars and twenty cents
so in your head you say wow you know so
what might cost me 10 12 15 bucks if i
lose
no big deal but if we continue the math
what happens let's take it out to nine
holes and see what is nine holes
you get out the nine holes and you go
wow i wasn't expecting 25 dollars
but we're only halfway there go ahead
flip the balance
11 12 now look what happens here we get
to the 13th hole four to nine dollars
we went from down here 25 bucks four
holes later we're at 409 how do we go
from 25 to 404
holes power of compounding watch what
happens these last holes
14th hole 15th hole 16th 17th
18th hole 13 107
okay so if you're a good golfer this is
what you'll go do next
next week when you get home right now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
percent chance of actually following
through but when you get motivated and
then you actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below
so i can celebrate you how much do you
advise
understanding the individual companies
or should it just be kind of set it
forget it by the index looking at once a
year then don't worry about it
i don't think you want to just do the
index because you want to have different
asset classes
if you look at the best investors in the
world they all understand that they're
going to be wrong
uh you've talked to ray dalio the
greatest hedge fund investor in the
history of the world
guy made a fortune in 2008 when everyone
else is losing money
and what does he tell you he says tony
you have to have money in each different
asset class because different
environments the environments will
change no matter how smart people think
they are they're going to be wrong
and you got to structure yourself so
you're able to make money no matter what
so you don't want just you know the
index but
what you do want to do is you do not
want to be probably somebody who's
trying to evaluate individual stocks
that's really you know somebody's going
to try and be a trader and in most cases
that's not going to work now if you're
warren buffett that's a different piece
but maybe better to invest with warren
buffett who's better at selection than
you are
than you trying to do it stock picking
nobody wins at it the best in the world
don't win you got people that are
supposed to be the best hedge fund guys
on earth and what's their track record
of the last seven years
it's pathetic they've not even matched
the market right and so that's why
you've seen this shakeup in the hedge
fund industry
because after you pay for fees even with
their brilliant minds
you end up lower than if you just own
the market itself so the answer to
question is you need to diversify every
investor
believes in diversification across
multiple
elements in other words you don't want
to just buy real estate you want
different assets or just the index like
you described that's a disaster
because there'll be times when the index
will get hit and you need something to
balance it out if you're only in one
place you're going to get hurt
and the pain will be so strong you'll
probably sell and then have a permanent
wound or a permanent
problem you don't want that to happen so
you need diversity across different
assets you don't want just one giant
piece of real estate
you want diversity within asset classes
so multiple pieces of real estate
or or owning the index is the example
you want diversification across
different economies and you want
diversification across
time if you want some awesome motivation
from simon sinek check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there jobs was the
rebel and he always was
against big business right um
all the visionaries that we know have
some sort of personal experience and
imagine a world that is different to the
one they live in now